there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock hello out there everybody
it's time for another episode of the 13
o'clock podcast yeah there's gonna be a
good show
this was actually Tom's idea yeah it was
my idea because I was involved in some
other [ __ ]
yeah I guess I could probably talk about
it I wanted to get that I wanted to put
Jenny on this case to get down to the
bottom of it it's uh it's it's an honor
you know it's kind of a current event
and some people some people are thinking
that this might relate in a way to the
epstein case we're gonna find out uh
yeah no um I didn't see anything
mentioning that but what's it thing is
is like online there's this it's being
called a conspiracy theory there's this
thing that's I've been trying to figure
it out for [ __ ] months now called
queue and whether or not this is some
kind of source coming out of the
government or if it's something that is
is a fraud and really I I I can't figure
it out it actually seems to be seems to
be true but I don't know if it's the
source of the information with this
queue thing I think it's I think the
source is other sources but that it's
kind of turned into almost kind of like
a fortune-telling device as if it's
predicted something you don't talking
about yeah I mean I don't think it's the
original source not yet but there's a
lot of people that don't really know
what this cue thing is but it's relevant
because this supposed cue source says
that the nexium case was I guess you
could say a secret part of the
government's effort to get the public
aware of sects cults and that this was
the first sex cult
case that was a bunch of rich people
that they wanted to expose to get them
ready for what Epstein was all about and
eventually leading to the fact that like
all the world's leaders or all the real
tough guys are all compromised been
compromised by these sex cults I don't
know there might be something to it
I am My Mind's open but I don't believe
anything until I see it in a court of
law you know I'm talking about it sounds
far-fetched
we'll just have to see I mean bill and
the thing about this far faster well the
thing about this is that people were
talking about nexium as being a cult way
back in 2003 it's just no one really
look at his kid yeah ISM okay stop it
it's just that no one really like listen
but no one really liked it didn't kind
of get onto the you know kind of wider
stage yeah until you know an
investigation in 2017 when you know
there's kind of like a famous actress
involved and yeah [ __ ] like that but
like I said people were warning about
like that Ross guy I can't wear what his
first name is but he's like a very
famous I've seen him on a bunch of like
Scientology documentaries you know he's
like a cult researcher and he was like
warning about this back in 2003 I think
he even got sued by these [ __ ]
yeah for saying that they were a cult
because he pretty much came out and said
I think it's a call to quote-unquote and
they kind of got all up his ass about it
yeah so people have like I said people
have been warning about this type of
[ __ ] since a long time ago now there are
some connections with this cult with
politicians there's a Republican guy
named Roger stone lives here in Florida
who evidently was a lawyer for them I
think if I remember correctly but he was
he dealt with them on a limited basis
evidently for like a few weeks and then
evidently he didn't want to [ __ ] with
them either after yeah well well they
gave money to like political campaigns
but I mean that they're doing the same
[ __ ] that Scientologists do that's what
we want to talk about although you know
you know we don't laugh at Scientology
either we the Santo this is very similar
to Scientology it seems like it stems
from the same route and it seems like it
has a lot of the same influences it's a
self-help improvement
it's like they even have a lot of the
same terminology she moved the camera
again hmm they even have like a lot of
the same terminology you know they they
use the word suppressives they use
ethics they use all that kind of stuff
and I feel like they like the guy that
runs it like God
yeah or knows about it and use the same
cuz he used a lot of time and in fact
this is pretty much Scientology with a
sex cult angle okay because I think
they're really the only thing that
Scientology doesn't have is that as far
as we know I mean you know well we'll
get to the case in a bit yeah just
wanted to put you on it to see what you
could dig up on it you know what I mean
to see if there's anything to this case
yeah well obviously there is because the
guy at the head of it got convicted okay
he doesn't get sentenced till summer
September 25th a couple of the actresses
that were also like kind of higher-ups
in there and like tried to recruit other
people into it have also been charged
and we're also found guilty although I
don't think like some of them like got
lesser sentences you know for testifying
against it and stuff right it's like I
said it's very similar to Scientology
where you get like people that got the
hell out of it and then you know came to
the media texts like I saw there's a
documentary on there was a document or
in 2020 about it um there was like I
think ane is doing a thing about it
I don't know if it's aired yet I think
it aired months ago but I couldn't find
it but I found the 2021 is on the ABC
website if you went in for free if you
want to watch that but yeah this is
basically this is this is the kind of
thing that it's like I I hate I hesitate
to say because I know that a lot of
people and I've said this about
Scientology too I know that a lot of
people that get into that later are not
idiots but it's just really hard for me
to I don't even think it's like a
question of intelligence I think it's a
question of a certain personality type
that's drawn to this type of thing yeah
like because anything the nexium cults
like the Scientology cult it's like
anything that's like any kind of
hierarchical corporate kind of like
thing it's I always like run away
not screaming like as fast as I possibly
could some people they just love it
but some people really like that kind of
thing and it's like you know I noticed
the you know the in the generations
especially the generations older than us
like our parents generation they fell
hook line and sinker for anaconda clean
cut corporate official appearance to
things yeah I mean yeah that as long as
it looked like it was approved of then
it must be correct yeah it was kind of
like the mentality but people are still
it seems like people are still falling
for that type of thing that's because
they believe in things that they see
yeah Charlie company's like wearing a
suit and like rocking about right if
you're wearing a suit suit it has a logo
it has a nice office if the colors are
correct oh they must then it must mean
they must know what they're talking
about that is not the case it must be it
must be approved of it must be the real
thing yeah I mean I think that's what
what I think that's what people are
seeing when they fall for this [ __ ] I do
fall for appearances I do find it
fascinating though and especially this
one like you know and we've done a
couple shows about Scientology like with
angry gay Pope and stuff and I had my
own Scientology experience because I
used to live in Clearwater and I have
worked at a company that was owned by
them which is a horrifying experience
even though they didn't really they
didn't like try to recruit me or
anything but they do like make you read
all that l ron Hubbard [ __ ] and they
do kind of like its it's like a soft
conversion that's what they're trying to
do but it's like luckily for me I don't
like that kind of [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah I
just love it I've worked for
corporations I just I just I associate
suits and corporate rules and corporate
imagery with just fake fakery yeah
that's yeah that's exactly how I see it
so it's like you know so so but I know
that not everybody's like that yeah so I
can see how this might appeal to some
people you know to an extent but I do
kind of feel like this this cult in
particular and I and I've seen this you
know people are preferred to other cults
this way too and they've and I saw like
another person talking about this cult
in particular you know it's the whole
frog in boiling water thing it's like
you kind of get
there and they make you take courses and
it seems to help you and it seems like
oh it's like my life is getting so much
better they're like you know helping me
out of my career and they're helping us
out but then like slowly slowly slowly
like stuff starts to ratchet up and
you've at this point you've invested so
much money and so much time into doing
this and you're thinking oh well it did
help me so it can't be bad so it's just
like inch-by-inch it just gets worse and
worse and before you know it you're
getting branded yeah so huge yeah yeah I
don't really understand I can't
understand how someone can just I don't
know say yeah this this corporation this
whole outfit is helping me I just never
really had that experience I haven't
either but you know I don't know I'm
just I'm basically what's off slowly I
don't know or maybe you don't have maybe
you don't didn't grow up with you know
parents or something I don't know well
because like it well like I said I think
and I think from birth I am a very like
I do not like any type of authoritarian
anything I don't like being told what to
do I don't listen and like if people do
tell me what to do I'll tell you I'm
gonna do it and then I'm not gonna do it
and I'm just gonna do it the way I said
who's gonna do it
you'd make a [ __ ] soldier well no that's
what I mean it's like that's why I never
joined because I just I don't have that
personality type I'm just like man [ __ ]
off I'm gonna do whatever I happen but I
you know I have to have basically a
[ __ ] brave commander I almost have to
[ __ ] fear fear and respect him I know
that I disobey then I'll be punished if
I if you if I can't be punished then I
don't really I don't care yeah it's just
I I don't like but I don't like any kind
of I mean like I said the military's
different because it's with a purpose
it's just I feel like I don't like this
kind of empty authoritarian you know
we're just gonna tell you what you
should do this that and the other thing
it's why I don't like self-help groups I
don't like anything like that because
it's like you guys don't know me it's
like you don't know how you're how to
help me it's like only I can help me I
liked military fighting units yeah I
could only be in like an infantry or
maybe you know armor even though friends
minded upgoing are more later on and
they just said it was boring compared to
the infantry but infantry gets on your
nuts
- you're not it gets on your nuts
well we were talking about it the other
day like you know in in the sense of and
I was talking to one of our listeners
about this as well because we were kind
of talking about the movie we saw that
2012 movie compliance the other day and
that's based on a true story and I
actually kind of want to do a whole show
about the cases that that the case that
that was based on because it's like
fascinating it just goes to show you
that so many people are used to just
like listening to whatever and a quote
unquote Authority tells them to do that
they will go to like absurd lengths and
the the thing about compliance and it's
based very much on like this one case
and it's pretty accurate it just goes to
show that at first you can see yeah I
could see how that would happen yeah I
could see how that would happens like if
somebody called the thing and said they
were a cop and said you need to do this
sudden it because nothing sounded that
crazy but then it just got crazier and
crazier and crazier and then like you're
just sitting there going how could you
not have but like I said once you've
already gone that far then you feel
stupid and you don't want to back out
it's like Walt I think that's what it is
because I mean they've done like was
that the wouldn't this day was the
Milgram experiment where they were show
like people in lab coats early people in
uniforms would come and like tell people
to do something and it's like most
people would like shock someone to death
not really but they thought they were
they would shock someone to death if
someone in authority told them to but
only if you ramped it up you know what I
mean only if you ramped it up
what's weird is that you know I don't
have the inclination to listen to like
corporate Authority like for instance
I'm in a drugstore and a dude in a
Walmart or at a drugstore in corporate
outfit you know what I mean
starts talking [ __ ] to me it's not gonna
work no even if I work for that say drug
store or Walmart or some kind of
corporation like Ford or something you
know I'm not really
I don't really care what they say well
now if it was a military or a government
organization maybe a little bit more you
know specific as one that you know like
I trust it but most of the time now been
at McDonald's or uh yeah or a
chick-fil-a and [ __ ] chicken and the
thing too is that even if someone says
they're a cop or says they're I mean
like in particular the case that they
talked about in compliance there was
this a dude on the phone that said it
was a cop and like people just bought it
yeah it cops I don't really trust cops
well no mean no one should gentlemen cop
it is you know I mean I mean maybe a
state policeman I probably trust him a
little bit more than just like a local
small-town cop you're gonna do it that
you got to do what they say they'll
[ __ ] kill you yeah this is the United
States tsunami but yeah I don't trust
everything it's like even if it's a real
cop I mean one you always have to worry
but it's like it's just a fake cop [ __ ]
I would like that stole a uniform or
whatever but even if it's a real cop
they can [ __ ] you up because a lot of
real cops have like hey I'm gonna pull
this girl over and raper you know a lot
of cops that happen a lot of cops didn't
do that no one no I didn't say that I
said you know I said that does happen it
does happen before yeah yeah so it's
like you know it doesn't even yeah it
doesn't have to be a fake cop it could
be a real cop well in some in some
police units you know the case except
quality control is not good yeah you
know well that's true yeah but yeah so
it this kind of like researching this
cult has kind of got me thinking about
because I was thinking about that movie
and I was thinking about the Scientology
[ __ ] that I had to go through the stupid
company I worked for and like how people
react to Authority and how they will do
just stupid [ __ ] that you would never do
on your own just because somebody told
you to so what's going on we have any uh
yeah yeah so we gotta do a couple of
shout outs before we start talking about
the show yeah we had some new patrons
this week we had one named Victoria E
hey there how are you doing also had a
new one named Sheena and we had one
named Joseph that when Oh Joseph that
went away for a while and then he came
back
so he returned though this week so yeah
so hi all you guys thank you very much
for your support also big news
faceless villain three is done yeah it's
not on audiobook yet yeah but I mean
today we're recording this on Friday I
uploaded the print version of the eBook
version today by the time this show
comes out it will probably be up yeah um
and as soon as it goes up I'm gonna
upload his audio book is done I just
have to upload it and that usually takes
between 10 to 14 days right so the print
audio book should be up by the time the
show comes out audio book will probably
be week or two like a week or two but
we'll announce it yeah and this is the
first audio book done with the new
equipment yeah so the sound quality is
very good with it yeah with the new life
and we'd even put out some of some crap
in that first couple years that we were
doing this but I think it's pretty much
pretty much all of it's been kind of
cleaned up I think the Steve Mara books
are recorded with the old microphones
right yeah I haven't got a runner gonna
get around and we're gonna clean those
up problems yeah and then but you got to
do that other thing we got to read you
got to do your your from your fiction
yeah that'll be the next product I'm
gonna do audiobook version yeah
eventually yeah
some of the other ones that you did I
think the audio quality is good enough
on them yeah but eventually the audio
quality on all the old stuff will be
good yeah real good
I mean I think that uh the Steve Myers
have a serviceable it's just not the
best yeah well yeah we had like the the
kind of start of the microphone a little
bit old microphone right yeah and since
then we've got like a bunch of different
we got a couple of yetis so we got that
really fancy one that I have set up in
this yeah the Yeti was okay microphone
not a great microphone thats what we use
for this separate that new professional
MOCA for microphone is a lot better it
just sounds a lot better well and it
sounds a lot better in the in that dead
room right too because we have the
little closet with all the yeah
eventually eventually a sound everything
everything's gonna be you know brought
up to new standards yeah you know I'm
trying to go back and fix everything and
clean
everything up and all that other kind of
stuff all right so let's start talking
about nexium and every time you say
nexium I would say that's the purple
pill right in that for [ __ ] yeah in
that for [ __ ] what's it for
indigestion indigestion yeah I thought
it was it's not for it's not boner pills
is it no yeah so I don't know why they
want to call it that it's not spelled
like that no next thing my think was
some kind of a [ __ ] it's Roman
numerals it's like and XIV M cuz he was
trying to be like [ __ ] fancy yeah
this I've been watching [ __ ] about this
all day and it's like this guy's like
such a [ __ ] douche a oh my god all
right but he's like an l ron hubbard
alarming all right
so okay so next is what they called
themselves a multi-level marketing
company it's fallen apart since then
since there were all these convictions
and stuff and that's very recent the
main guy was just convicted in late June
of 2019 and he'll be sentenced in
September a long time yeah 15 years of
life is what he's looking at he's
looking at you know forty years because
there was a lot of charges yeah yeah so
it's gonna get thirty years deservedly
so I mean he is just like one of the
most punchable dudes seriously I don't
know why anybody would think he was
awesome but anyway so this was started
out as a multi-level marketing company
based out of Albany New York now what it
initially was supposed to do was it was
offering what they called executive
success programs what that [ __ ] is I
don't know I don't know I don't do this
corporate jargon kind of like some
Scientology would try to offer you
that's what I mean and they so they use
a lot of big negation they yeah they
have like all the same they hit it's all
the same [ __ ] they have like all that
same like jargony type of corporate
speak they charge you like thousands and
thousands of dollars for all these
courses and [ __ ] it's the same it's the
same exact [ __ ] thing and yet some
people [ __ ] fell for it again yeah
even though pretty much everybody now
knows in psychology what yeah this is
the real one but this one's real yeah
it's just crazy
it's funny because all that stuff was
kind of based on things that
Aleister Crowley was working on Aleister
Crowley and what was his name
God from The Satanic Church Anton LaVey
yeah because Crowley he thought you know
he and his buddies figured that you
could sell magical teaching you know I
mean if he had ended in blocks and you
made him pay to get higher and higher
it's a it's a scam
well yeah clearly he's a [ __ ] scam
and like I said this guy nexium wasn't
even this guy's first thing and he'd
already been like done for doing a
pyramid scheme before and they were like
hey knock that [ __ ] off and then he just
like renamed it into something else like
like a good con man does she was like as
far as I know like I said the sex cult
thing that Scientology doesn't have that
and as far as I know these [ __ ]
never tried to like petition the IRS and
makes a word they were religion right
maybe because they didn't think of it I
don't know but you know they would have
known everything about Scientology yeah
that's what I'm thinking um I also get
like a big vibe of like this is very
similar if anybody remembers like 60s
and 70s that thing they called esthe it
was like Verner or heart or whatever
that guy's name was that kind of like
self-improvement kind of brouhaha all
that kind of crap that's good it kind of
reminds me event and it also reminds me
the way that a lot of the followers like
talked about the guy that runs it Keith
Ranieri the way they talked about it it
sounded like the cult of personality
that developed around and Rand okay yeah
yeah it it reminds me of that right like
where she could do no wrong and she was
like the smartest person ever and like
you can question her because you know
even your taste in movies was like
objective and if you liked the wrong
movie then you were obviously wrong and
you region and all those other kind of
stuff it's very very much like that
because this guy comes off like he's
like the smartest dude on the planet the
most ethical dude on the planet he'd you
know he can control the weather that's
then the other thing and these
[ __ ] start coming at you with
ethics l ron Hubbard so I can just
that's what I mean it's just like I
heard oh well ron Hubbard that's his
ghost coming through the ethics and
morality earth to Canada can weave a
twisted web I mean
that's all just opinion really I mean
well most of it you can make anything
seem ethical or unethical if you're if
you've got a silver enough tongue well
and that's exactly what that's exactly
what yeah I'm getting real careful
preachers you know people teaching
ethics and lawyers you know it's all
that same [ __ ] yeah and that's exactly
what yet this kind of [ __ ] is ya serve
your own interests
Nicky decisions based upon what's good
for you now well other [ __ ]
yeah I mean as long as you're not you
know [ __ ] with somebody else yeah that
person is that's true yeah that's a bad
person is [ __ ] you know [ __ ] over a
bunch of other people well yeah then
[ __ ] over the progress and have at it
yeah somebody's in your way you might
have to move that person out of your way
yeah yeah so alright so then so nexium
like I said it started out as this kind
of marketing company now as it went on
there were these other little things
that developed that were like tendrils
of it the most infamous of these was
called das which was like it was no
computer no it is but it actually stood
for like a Latin term meaning like
dominant or something or other but it
actually translates to master over
slaves women okay so that was like their
their women's group yeah this is a real
special this group is like super super
misogynistic it's like it's very very
strange they attracted a bunch of women
it did and I don't really get it well I
think there are just some women that
need need a man tell them what to do
they're kind of yeah these girls
definitely had some issues yeah because
like I said it's founded by Keith
Ranieri now and he has been convicted of
all the charges probably the most famous
member is the actress Alison Mack who
most famous for small but Smallville she
actually went to trial along with him
because she admitted now she pleaded
guilty he's pleaded he pleaded not
guilty but she came forward and said
that she had recruited women that it was
her idea to do the branding that it was
this and the other thing which is really
weird because she just seems like she
just seems like this little blonde
actress you know this cute little blonde
actress and like why she was up to all
this nefarious [ __ ] on her really now
now before um
nexium started Renier had this Ranieri
rather had this business that was called
consumers byline no hold on we're going
further where is this all happening
Albany New York was their base but they
have like it's like Scientology they
have like little they don't huh they
don't call them orgs but nexium started
in 1998 but he had a similar thing
before that okay but that was when next
scene was found was 1998 not really not
really old not really so okay so before
he started nexium he had this thing
called consumers byline
which was I'm not entirely sure what it
was like I saw like a corporate [ __ ]
yeah some corporate [ __ ] that I don't
really get yeah the bit every time I
hear it I just wanna barf yeah if you're
in a New England yuppie you know that
it's looking for a job you might get
suckered in by something called consumer
byline maybe you might be able to make a
buck off of that but they probably run
through your ass yeah that's you know
it's just a the kind of way they would
name something like flypaper to attract
you know yeah corporate wannabes it had
something to do with it almost seems
like a shopping club type of thing you
know what I mean but I'm not entirely
sure what it was like I was watching a
documentary and they had my something
like Amway I think it was like sort of
like that
yeah but I saw like they I was watching
a documentary about it and they had like
some old like commercials like it looked
like this late night like infomercials
like from TV and simply for the 90s and
where it had this douche like talking
about it a douche yeah it's probably
something like Amway I think that's
pretty much what it was like from from
what I could glean from the commercial
cuz I'm like you cannot call it am way
we're an Amway light or we're nother
version
and we got a recast you get it's nothing
like nothing like gambling except um
pretty much as soon as he started like
trying to hock that [ __ ] the New York
Attorney General was like yeah that's
like Amway and that's a pyramid scheme
okay yeah so so I don't think Amway is a
pyramid well they around all that [ __ ]
yeah but it's like clearly he was I this
you buy these products and then you go
out selling yeah and then you get other
people to join in and you yeah yeah I
remember one of my relatives they're
trying to me I think with that - yeah I
think with Amway that was trying to sell
generic products to people and you got
bonuses if you got new customers and
they could sell it to and it was trying
to form a new economy yeah but that
doesn't happen in that couldn't happen
today in an age of the hitter that eBay
no it was just back in the 70s yeah it
seemed like that was kind of I think the
heyday for that is past maybe I don't
maybe not maybe yeah my uncle used to
buy some of their stuff yeah it was
actually good I health bars and yeah
yeah the quality was good it tasted good
and I think the prices were pretty good
but what they were doing is they were
you joined up it's kind of like joining
Sam's Club yeah in a way you paid for a
membership but then you could buy all
this stuff from there and you were kind
of expected to sell it to other people
too but they mostly did they mostly just
bought it
why didn't use it themselves well that's
probably what they were hoping what
happened right yeah that's probably yeah
there's like you're putting this
middleman in there with a team you need
to be a minute of one's like why don't
you just sell that [ __ ] to like
customers and then the end so I don't
know how fake Amway was I mean I did eat
some of theirs it's still around as far
as I know it's just a way of another way
of buying products directly from a
manufacturer maybe you get a better deal
on it I guess yeah I suppose I do you
know like I said I never really looked
into it because it always man that's
good on the store yeah that's what I
mean it's like it's especially these
days yes not hard but yeah so pretty
much immediately he comes out with his
consumers by line thing New York
Attorney General was like hey that's a
pyramid scheme knock that [ __ ] off so he
didn't get in like super big trouble or
anything at that time this was in
nineteen
96 but he had to sign like a consent
order that said that he wouldn't do that
type of like chain distribution type of
[ __ ] anymore and he had to pay a $40,000
fine yeah but return to setup ham way
yeah pretty much yeah
so undaunted Keith Ranieri in 1998 and
his second-in-command whose name is
Nancy Saltzman founded nexium supposedly
a quote unquote personal development
company offering executive success
programs or ESPs okay cuz that again I'm
getting the Scientology vibe it's like
everything has to be little acronyms and
[ __ ] this is just making me very nervous
he's trying to find a hustle yeah okay
right NAMM ways dick you couldn't do
that tried to ride amway's dick but
couldn't do it the law stop who sees
he's gonna instead ride LRH l ron
Hubbard's dick yeah and make his own
version of Santa something kind of like
Scientology that's that that's exactly
Scientology offers that to will help you
in your acting career and your yeah you
know and in your personal life will give
you the communications course that's the
first one yeah just in case you don't
know how to [ __ ] talk I had that yeah
I understand communication and like I
said reading the [ __ ] because I had to
do these courses the first half-hour of
every workday and I've mentioned this
before you had to do like Elrond Harbor
courses communication course blah blah
blah and it's like reading it he's a
crazy person he was a crazy person
clearly well I think people that join
Scientologists make it stick and stay in
there they're crazy too so it's it's
crazy you have to have a little bit of a
screw loose I have to say because I'm
reading that going this person is
clearly I would not go to a
Scientologist to learn how to
communicate every one of them I've
[ __ ] seen on the Internet
I ran into a couple of minute Starbucks
one time those mothers are nuts yeah no
[ __ ] they're nuts I worked with the
other day full of them they're nuts and
they think that they know more than you
and though they don't even know what
anything is that's what I mean yeah oh
that drove me crazy yeah
there is nothing that drives me well I
don't know this is a pretty long list
but there's nothing that drives me crazy
er than a stupid person
there's mark and that's exactly what
Scientologists are how like one of these
dudes like a sheet of cam or somebody
that came from one of these 1980s ninja
schools going to the [ __ ] MMA and
trying to teach them how to fight yeah
yeah everybody would laugh at you and
then go into a crimson stain yeah 98
pound dudes [ __ ] build ninja stars
and a blue ninja suit and [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
out of here we'll see any time so I'm
always this is why any type of [ __ ] I
gotta levitate it yeah it's like yeah
and they just think they can partake
there weren't even [ __ ] ninjas that's
a that's a myth did you know that there
were no ninjas I know yeah the samurai
thought they were ninjas but this
shinobi just made shinobi just meant
covert operations there's just other
soldiers doing them okay do a show on
samurai and I'm sampling on ninjas yeah
I better probably actually be a
fungineer just ninjas and martial arts
in the [ __ ] that is Marshall because
he's obsessed with this now he's but
it's paranormal it claims to be
paranormal
yeah you're right yeah claims to be
paranormal and I kind of believed it
when I was a kid in a certain way a lot
of people did but looking back on and
seeing what they're doing now like oh
yeah okay but some of those guys could
fight so it was very confusing yeah yeah
well it's better if you're gonna have a
scam or a hustle yeah it's better to at
least kind of look like you know what
you're doing and not look like a total
idiot
yeah there were some people just
hustling through the kungfu [ __ ]
scene there did they didn't they were
totally bullshitting or there were some
guys like Chuck Norris that really
couldn't beat your ass yeah you know
what I mean but he was beating people's
asses he's a fighter
yeah and he didn't make the same claims
that you know another guy said that you
know he can become invisible because
he's a ninja you know he could throw chi
balls and [ __ ] you know well it right of
all of ya bum foo dojo some of them are
very much like a Scientology org their
codicil and mine powers
yeah and this was
this was kind of like that too and check
this out this is an element of LARPing
check out we'll check out this Segway
that I'm about to make is that one thing
that they do in nexium is they have
something like a martial arts belt thing
except their scarves but I think it's
the same colors like you know it's white
to start and then yellow and green or
whatever blue brown whatever so they do
the same kind of thing so they wear
these colored scarves so you know what
rank they are so I guess you know if you
can like treat them like [ __ ] or write
boss them around or whatever so they
have that so see I tied it in with the
whole March I'm gonna do martial arts
show so okay so these two choads
start this [ __ ] thing for corporate
self-improvement blah-dee-blah I guess
it's kind of like personal semblance but
the only people that could afford eight
were like rich corporate types because
the classes just like Scientology were
like thousands of thousands of dollars
they would do like these [ __ ] things
called intensive so Scientology asked oh
my god it's freaking me out and you know
the class is like $25,000 what the [ __ ]
are they doing in there
who knows they're doing like a kind of
on the 20/20 thing they actually got
some like little secret footage like
looking in the window like while they
were doing some [ __ ] and they're doing
like you know they all like do the
chants and stuff it's like when you work
at Walmart and they kind of make you
like the happy Walmart [ __ ] chant and
god I hate that [ __ ] but it's terrible
but so know what civilians would want to
do do that that's what yeah we do that
in the army but we were singing old war
songs and [ __ ] it's like why no we want
to work at a place it's like below RAAA
I'm like yeah whatever just give me my
paycheck okay that's the only [ __ ]
free getting a paycheck and putting on
and what in a nameplate and going out
and killing some other [ __ ] and then
having your friends die and [ __ ] to
fight some kind of [ __ ] battle
there's a big difference between wow
yeah why would a civilian want to do
that [ __ ] like what will net well and it
doesn't have if you work at Walmart you
don't really have much of a choice yeah
cuz I get fine no these
going to this training schools corporate
trainings to [ __ ] sing corporate songs
as [ __ ] that doesn't have the same
impact as [ __ ] you know I mean dudes
it kill other dudes for a living it's
just like I don't know it's not a
Solomon Asian I used to work I used to
work with this girl who was she was a
manager but she was like super super
into she was just super into like all
that corporate kind of so she had all
the books like the one minute manager
and all that kind of stuff and she was
so into it and it's just like she always
wanted the department to go like oh you
can't be go and do like team-building
extras I'm like please please no I can't
leave now you can't be a good leader by
instinct and [ __ ] you can't be trained
to be a good leader it's like I don't
know if that's true I mean you do have
to have well you do have to have a
certain personality yeah better
making me hone sure you have to have the
framework what the corporation needs
like what information they need missus I
understand that I understand training I
don't understand this rah-rah the
company yeh it's like that's basically
what they're doing is they're trying to
brainwash you into like doing all this
work and not getting any reward for it
you either have that's what they're
doing you either have a leadership
personality or you don't just some
people just it just can't be trained in
them usually usually when the military
has training like that doesn't really
have much to do with the person's
personality it just has to do with their
training upon some kind of a paperwork
mechanism of how to interact say with
army bureaucracy that's what the
training is about how to fill out forms
yeah basically you know I mean for
leadership type schools well not really
I guess it depends but I mean you know
companies just do it because they want
you to do a bunch of with you know they
want you to feel like you're part of
this quote-unquote team like oh we're
all in this together and stuff like that
because I've never really worked that's
[ __ ] because they could fire you for
anything and like not even care ya know
I mean and all the backstabbing and
everything going on inside of
corporation cheating each other trying
to steal each other's hours and all that
kind of [ __ ] that they do you trusted
another person in the corporation you're
a [ __ ] child
I just can't they're all your
competition like I've
no I liked people I've worked with I've
been friends people with people I've
worked with and didn't mind hanging out
with them and stuff but in general it's
like if I have to go like after hours
like for some fun no I'm not doing that
no I'm sick that's one of the one of
them like if you are you paying me to
hang out with you know that I'm not
going it's one of the reasons why they
outsource to our generations jobs to
China and stuff is because we wouldn't
do it was just us we were too smart for
that [ __ ] that it's a really good movie
that you guys want to watch about this
office space everybody yeah yeah I
wouldn't do that to ya everybody did
that's one origin of it classic your
generation went through that I think a
lot of those jobs are gone probably yeah
yeah all that yeah I'm gonna need you to
come inside yeah
well you don't need to do it anymore
because every can work from home now
those same people that were in that
office would be working from their home
office yeah
telecommuting telecommuting and [ __ ] I
just kind of want everything to go like
that cuz if you don't have to go in and
like hang out with other people and look
at them and stuff then that'll be just
turn the work again yeah yeah it's like
as long as I get it done it's like I
don't need somebody like you know Barkin
down my snorkel all day it was a 1950s
mentality of a boss walking around
managing you and he doesn't know how to
operate a computer yeah yeah what is
that what's that called formatting a
hard drive yeah somebody needs to put
paper what is that really what does that
mean well yes so make it five times what
you make well yeah that's what that was
one thing I always hate is it always
seemed like people that were charging
you didn't know [ __ ] about yeah about
how do the job they were in their 50s
back then they were just the babysitters
yeah basically I don't need a [ __ ]
baby with all the work yeah it's just
like that makes me very resentful I
don't like it yeah so this whole thing
and I love this [ __ ] quote from this
dude his main emphasis was to have
people experience more joy in their
lives who who knew that by people he met
him oh yeah having more money and sex
slaves yeah so that was he's like I
didn't say what people I just said
people yeah I met me man
so I love this as well so during the
seminars that nexium would give you're
supposed to call you can't call Keith
Ranieri by his name you have to call him
Vanguard okay he's the bad guard it's
his title it's like it as soon as I
heard that I was just like oh no I think
I just threw up in my mouth a little bit
but yeah it was like that it was like
somebody that knew him said he got it
from a video game right like a video
game there's a video game called
Vanguard yeah I remember it leave us
been about my age but he said but he
said it was because oh because he much
like and Rand was all like oh I came up
with this amazing like philosophical
framework that no one ever thought of
before in the history of ever
and I'm like on the vanguard of it this
is a new philosophical movement so you
have to call me Vanguard now the the
woman that was like his right-hand woman
Nancy's Altman she got the much less
awesome title of prefect so it kind of
sounds like you know she was Hermione
and the Harry Potter universe there she
can look at the little prefix but as we
will find out later on this is not um
you didn't have a very high opinion of
women in general it seemed like he
thought they were much less than men
they were irrational they were this that
and the other thing so I feel like that
was almost kind of like a little dig
yeah a door even though she co-founded I
don't know maybe not I just got that
kind of feeling that well I'm gonna be
Vanguard you can be prefect
I'm like what
oh well it's just gonna be like anything
else like with martial arts and and
Scientology there's an there there's an
element of [ __ ] live-action role play
and LARPing
yeah and that's LRH and Scientology
okay there's role-playing involved yeah
well Leo smothers can make a lot of
money man the sign the Church of
Scientology's [ __ ] huge they got
desert secret bases and [ __ ] I know I
wish I'd have thought of that I bet a
lot of people wish there was that I
thought of that well they will this
douche that thought he thought of it
need he did it for a little while right
he was making enough money that when
they arrested his dumb ass he was like
at this big [ __ ] $10,000 a week big
mansion importantly Arda so he must have
been making some money off all these
suckers and sucker born every minute
clearly there are some people just
really want approval it's I feel like
and it's bad because I feel like look
there's nothing wrong with
self-improvement in general but this is
not how you do it that's yeah it's like
and and I think that's what's makes what
makes these kind of groups so insidious
is that you know there's nothing wrong
with like wanting to be better sure job
or you know wanting to like deal with
your emotions better or whatever it is
but the fact that you go to these
seminars and spend thousands and
thousands of dollars yes and then end up
getting like sucked into this [ __ ]
[ __ ] where you're like working for free
and all this other kind of [ __ ] same
thing that Scientology does it's like
there's just better wasted it's like
seriously you could self improve for
free just go to the library and check a
book out just read some [ __ ] on the
internet anything or you can stuff and
prove for real pick something that you'd
interest you that's difficult and go out
and do it say like rock climbing yeah go
climb a [ __ ] big-ass Rock yeah all
right that's just hard yeah go [ __ ]
you know but we'll climb Mount Everest
and ships free for freezing [ __ ] cold
become a diver or something there's a
lot of hard stuff that people who are
not all that tough can learn to do
yeah and they can improve themselves and
what challenge yourself yeah once you do
that you'll feel like a lot better
because now dead something yeah
there's [ __ ] bodybuilding mind
building spirit building go out camp and
go survive got in the desert and try to
survive with you know minimum stuff
train yourself up go with a group of
guys that survive out there for a couple
weeks then come on back it's five we
just do it in the army all-time field
exercises well like I said you don't
even necessarily have to do anything
like physical you could just like
[ __ ] write a story paint a [ __ ]
picture just do something hands-on who
you are that makes you feel like you
accomplished something it makes you feel
a lot better about yourself yeah I
always thought to try to find your
weaknesses find a weakness in yourself
and confront it and try to strengthen
that weakness yeah and then you'd find
something that your what are your
strengths right and then you hone that
yeah so you know I mean do stuff like
that it's very effective yeah and a lot
of people's problems you know having
these first world problems you know I
mean their lives are not that hard and
they're spoiled and then you start
feeling very miserable because they're
not challenged so they start
disintegrating go out and challenge
yourself you know and I feel like the
the weird thing about it is that the
nexium group and also in Scientology
also it's like they didn't necessarily
want I mean they wanted vulnerable
people in a way maybe like emotionally
vulnerable or somebody that had [ __ ]
they could exploit but they wanted
people that were already successful like
it with money because a lot of the
people that came into next scene were
like big actresses there were already
millionaires they were already you know
they had like that one of those douches
from Enron like took classes there
that's like the daughter of the Mexican
press not hard oh [ __ ] like that no I'm
just saying it was people that already
had money that already had success that
like you know poor ass broke-dick people
like me I be looking at it be like what
the [ __ ] problems could you possibly
have millionaire well I'll tell you this
I'll tell you something this is based on
my personal experience being a Salesman
up in Boston you know
up in Wellesley Weston Dover both some
of the richest people I'd sold in those
areas in my experience it's much easier
to sell to a very rich and intelligent
person because they'll listen to you
alright go try to sell some dumbass you
can't sell them anything no I can't sell
them anything so somebody's intelligent
and powerful people can kind of be
pulled in more easily because they have
an imagination yeah and you can play on
that imagination yeah alright and then
start to convince them of things that in
the end are not true it's easier to calm
them yeah go to some streetwise
[ __ ] from the hood hey man let
me tell you something get the [ __ ] out
of here yeah they had to spend lunch you
yeah they have defenses well because
they're used to getting [ __ ] exactly
a lot of these rich very high-class
people do not have the same street
defenses cuz they're not used to getting
they're not used to it right so you can
turn their imagination and their
intelligence back on themselves because
they don't think that they could ever be
fooled yeah and the best thing to use
against them is things like logic yeah
that's that's what this guy was yeah
logic has a lot of problems in logic
because it I can sit there and logically
explain to you that your life really
isn't worth living
and if give it enough time maybe I could
get you to kill yourself that's some
weird [ __ ] huh dudes have done it yeah
cult leaders have done it yeah well yeah
of course yeah sorry famously yeah so
there's a certain amount of weakness in
intelligence and there's a certain
amount of strengthen being stupid go try
to pull a con on a shark
watch what happens yeah they just bite
you problem too is that like I said I
think sometimes people that are
intelligent sometimes you have a blind
spot yeah of your own weaknesses or your
ingenuity because sometimes smart people
like they know that they're smart and so
they think that other people can't trick
them or they think they're smarter than
other people so they don't think anybody
else can pull [ __ ] over all right that's
not the case right
you know even the smartest richest
[ __ ] got weaknesses
well yeah everyone does and a good con
man could find those yeah you know I
mean [ __ ] they're dudes that do it to
women they find the [ __ ] weakness in
a beautiful woman and a lot of times her
weakness is that she's beautiful next
thing you know she's [ __ ] just
miserable
yeah in an abusive relationship you know
I mean thinking feeling bad about
herself
that's this guy did a lot of yeah he
might a woman as beautiful tell her
she's [ __ ] ugly that's what he would
do she's skinny you tell her she's too
[ __ ] skinny or she's not skinny
enough that kind of [ __ ] well yeah and
like I said there was one thing that he
did and I was actually I was listening
to there's a really good The Canadian
Broadcasting Company did a like a eight
part podcast and they interviewed one of
the actresses of a Canadian actresses
Edmondson her last name is yeah and she
was in this for a while and then she got
the [ __ ] out and she got branded the
whole deal and she was like talking
about it and it was like heartbreaking
like listening to how it sucked her in
and something that they did a lot and he
would do this and like he got like some
of the other women that were in charge
to do this as well
was negging yeah was that mean that
means that's like a thing that like that
pickup artist type dudes do where it's
like you go up to a woman like in a bar
or something like that and you'd be like
that's a stupid hat because they're
trying to get a reaction
well one they're trying to get a
reaction get you to like want to please
them like I'm not like you know what I
mean because so they think that that's
something that works I mean rather than
most women just like kicking them in the
balls if they did that but that's
something that they did in this a lot
they and one thing that he would do like
I said and why I said that this cult was
kind of like misogynistic was that he
had this belief that women were
genetically inferior they were
genetically irrational they were
genetically manipulative and they
couldn't help it so you had to come into
this group to fix that you know what I
mean so he was coming at you from the
angle of you are already [ __ ] up
naturally so you have to come here and
we have to help you and fix all this
[ __ ] that's wrong with you you know what
I mean so he he very much had that kind
of mindset well there's something to
that anybody who joins a cult has a
problem though he's already got
something on well and they know that if
you join a cult there's an issue yeah
yeah and like I said it's the ones like
this though I mean Scientology like I
said everybody knows that's [ __ ] now
but this one if you didn't know because
there are other companies as far as I
know that do this kind of like
team-building corporate [ __ ] and
everything like that that aren't cults
but so if you just went to like a couple
of classes and it seemed like just the
regular run-of-the-mill corporate
[ __ ] that everyone else is doing
then you wouldn't think anything about
it so that's what kind of made this one
a little more insidious I think just
because it didn't seem like that at
first you know what I mean it just
seemed like regular corporate [ __ ]
well how does it go what's next so I was
gonna say like other than you know all
the you know people that were in it
Linda Evans was in it for a little while
some of the the two women that were
[ __ ] they were heirs to the Seagram
liquor fortune they actually funded a
lot of it they gave him like a hundred
and fifty million dollars or something
like that some ridiculous amount couple
of other like actresses from Smallville
a couple from Battlestar Galactica and
Nicki Kline I think she was on the
Battlestar Galactica she was in it so
much like Scientology the training that
nexium uses is supposedly it's a trade
secret which I'm sure it's like so
original legit so there's all these like
non-disclosure agreements so if you
publish some of their [ __ ] just like
Scientology does they will sue you so
they do the same kind of crap you know
what I mean so this this is what made me
think of mmm what you were saying before
about logic and everything so the
technique that they use like to improve
your life and bring you joy or whatever
the [ __ ] they're doing they call it
rational inquiry which anytime anybody
says if they like
just run its quickly it's Jenny's heard
me say it many times if I get into an
argument I say stop trying to reason
with me
I don't do with her stop trying to Ruiz
reason with me I cannot be reasoned with
that usually shuts it down usually when
somebody's reasoning with me you know
they're trying to reason me into
something that is not within my not in
my advantage
trying to get me to do something that's
good for them and not me don't reason
with me not reasonably reason isn't is
it the deciding factor and what I do
it's more the gut I kind of gut and what
seems to make sense
yeah not have thought about yeah yeah
instinct a lot of times well this like I
said I I kind of feel like if you have
to come forward and say this is rational
inquiry then it's not you know what I
mean it's kind of like it's not what
they're talking about well yeah and it's
kind of like when people come out and
say that they're cool they're not cool
it's like if you were cool you wouldn't
have to tell other people you're cool
right if you're a cool you don't give a
[ __ ] if you're cool or not exactly
that's that's what I'm saying that's
another person's opinion of you so if
you're say that you're rational and all
this other kind of [ __ ] then clearly
it's not wrong then there's something
the matter wrong now the thing about the
thing about um this [ __ ] dude that
runs this [ __ ]
Vanguard yeah you're a little 60s rock
group called bang there was yeah I
remember that when they like just kind
of hit the music I like kind of like you
know for a second I thought wonderfully
can Paul no no a Brazilian Bar was named
a [ __ ] bad
Donavan something like that kind of fly
fly like the Sun remembers like that
that's something like that baby that
wasn't vanguard yeah but I remember
sounded like that I was gonna say isn't
that a deodorant but no that's right
guard yeah they still make breaker
that's what I'm that's what I'm gonna
call him for the rest of the show
because any guard in a way I got wrong
guard but um I well I kind of got mad
because I was watching the 22 anything
and it's like they called him by his
name some of the time too but they but
sometimes they would call him Vanguard
I'm like stop doing that his title
Vanguard of humanity that's the same
thing Scientologists edge Commodore they
own Commodore Commodore save that top
crews what are we calling him I don't
know he's got all kinds of medals of
Valor and [ __ ] I'm not gonna talk bad
about Tom I feel sorry for Tom I mean I
think that I think he's a good guy I
think he got wrapped up in something did
it was that yeah yeah I know I think
he's good guy just I feel bad for him so
this is movies annoy me but I do feel
kind of bad for him that he got a second
into that I think he's a good man okay
he's a little nuts though I think it's
hard to tell he might not have been nuts
when he started but he's for sure no no
sorry it's hard to tell because um I
don't think I don't think he'll ever
really know who Tom Cruise is he's
constantly putting on a show for the fur
yeah like that so I always wonder if
that happened with a lot of actors like
particularly ones that are like really
get into their roles and stuff it's like
do they like forget what their own
identity is I could see that happening
I've I've heard you know I've heard guys
talk about him you know other actors and
stuff and just based on what they say
he's an intelligent guy he's very
competent he's in really good shape he
knows a lot about motorcycles and stuff
and guns he knows he's not dummy but I
think Scientology's got him by the balls
too yeah yeah I think a little bit I
don't think he can leave if he leaves
they'll give up all his secrets that he
said during confession yeah yeah and
that's exactly the same kind of [ __ ]
that that's why I feel [ __ ] yeah and I
think maybe they did help him in the end
I think they helped him but I also think
they used him yeah and then I think that
they kind of trapped him and that's the
thing it's like it seems like a lot of
these groups I mean this group like I
was talking about asked earlier and
stuff where I mean some percentage of
people that are in and even some
percentage of people that are in
Scientology that maybe aren't like in
the [ __ ] you know that aren't like
living on the premises and stuff they're
still living relatively normal lives and
stuff and just go in and take classes a
lot of them have said like it helped
them in their life and stuff and I'm not
gonna you know I'm not gonna [ __ ] on
their say that
they're crazy for thinking that maybe it
did help them and but in the case of Tom
Cruise and Scientology new you in case
you guys have never don't really know
the show too well and I saw Scientology
very well and so so does Jenna you did a
lot of studies on it talk to people that
have dealt with Scientology and then
protested it and everything I think in
the case of Tom Cruise Tom Cruise got
the [ __ ] red carpet treatment by
Scientology yeah Tom Cruise was already
an actor by the time he joined
Scientology he's already had a lot of
buddy some when you're an actor you're
pretending you're not really the real
thing he's pretending to be hero but
he's not really a hero he's pretending
to be able to fly jets and do all this
[ __ ] superhuman [ __ ] but he doesn't
do that in real life well how is he
gonna get this credit to this street
cred for his own you know I mean for his
own peace of mind to let him know that
he really is a competent person what's
he gonna do is you gonna join the army
no he can't join the army he's gonna
join the airforce no no he's gonna join
something to give him a official
training yeah and the closest thing that
he's gonna get to what he's looking for
it would be Scientology yeah cuz it's
kind of like the name it's kind of like
I don't think he's a seorak member no I
probably gave him all kinds of cool
little training and him and David
Miscavige riding [ __ ] Ducatis and
[ __ ] he shoots guns and does [ __ ] like
that and he's got his own [ __ ] you
know version of Scientology [ __ ] Navy
SEAL [ __ ] going on that's that's what it
is yeah hey I did some real [ __ ] yeah
now evidently I've heard that you know
David Miscavige thinks he's a [ __ ]
tool but they're friends too evidently
but spoiler alert it's actually David
Miscavige that is the tool David
Miscavige me David Miscavige Tom Cruise
all hanging out same size okay it would
be awesome all riding motorcycles
together guys you know right ads of gold
bases all right I'd be a heretic though
because I don't have my [ __ ] you're a
suppressive Morrison
yeah I'm an SP I haven't progressed
along the bridge you know I mean but
here's the
man I could probably [ __ ] run it with
those douchebags fry hold my own because
all the [ __ ] that they do in Scientology
they kind of do that in the military too
you know
yeah all the hazing and [ __ ] smoking
people and [ __ ] like that in the
discipline we play those games also yeah
so you know [ __ ] coming with that crazy
[ __ ] I shall mind-control to house a
[ __ ] like Tom Cruise gonna talk
badass a man with a [ __ ] ass cheeks
like that today he's going back into
bootie warrior bootie warrior somebody
said that we should like the last
episode we did that we should make a
drinking game out of every time you said
bootie warrior to take a shot boy I'm
like killer failure he's Johnson booty
war yeah please don't do that we do not
endorse it we do not endorse that place
you know Tom Cruise is cute is Tom
Cruise is that brother [ __ ] better
not be talking [ __ ] about me hey he's
got better motorcycles I'm faster though
[Laughter]
[ __ ] I'm talking guys with motorcycles
we're talking [ __ ] about nexium and
Scientology you're gonna get so sued
yeah and and I'm feeling pretty good
over this [ __ ] tequila we're gonna
say what's the time is it time for a
break in probably yes if we're partying
our it's gonna be a good show
cuz they're really just starting to get
to the meeting I know we haven't even
like totally started talking well we've
kind of been talking about it like kind
of round that side alright so we're
about ready without even realizing it so
what we're gonna take a break right now
when we get back we will talk some more
about the nexium cult and probably the
more about Scientology and maybe more
about Tom Cruise's little tight but if
he gets drunk enough I hope they bring
that up to keep Tom Cruise under control
and [ __ ] get sporty with me in
my mind and I have to refer to his tight
ass and he's gonna back that up
[ __ ] prettiest him can't talk
sporty to me like that I'll [ __ ] [ __ ]
him up I love Utah he really does he
loves awkward yeah all right we'll be
back in just a few minutes
[Music]
[Music]
would you try will you stop it stop
doing it
stop doing it
no no do dad turn up the furniture
no no stop tearing it up stop tearing it
up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah we're back back talking about Tom
Cruise ass that's all he talked about
through the whole break you yeah that's
all right yeah
mostly we just got more ice in our dress
so so it's it's like Scientology what
they're doing but they're abusing it
like Scientology's not abusing it at
another level yeah as far as I know as
far as I know all the [ __ ] up talked
about Scientology
there isn't any like official sexual
abuse going on evidently and LRH didn't
and he had little teenage girls around
him all the time
yeah I never really heard anything which
I which is very unusual because usually
that's a main component I mean they do
other [ __ ] they starve people and work
people and eat them and stuff but as far
as I know they make people get abortions
Scientology just they don't want to
Scientology as close as I can tell or a
bunch of true believers they're under
this [ __ ] because they really believe it
they're not in it for the sex yeah yeah
that that very well maybe I'm not really
sure what was that little man well they
ain't come here what happened it was a
weird-ass sound of the cat baby
yes is she all right oh yes what
happened she wants to go out from the
Badgers oh no you're not doing that yeah
so Catherine area the dude that started
nexium now I should know that I don't
think I mentioned this before but he was
one of those guys just like l ron
hubbard that had this like big
spectacular like oh i'm a big super
genius I was talking employed sentences
when I was one I could read I was too
bloody boom blah and all this other kind
of [ __ ] everybody knew that I was like
the smartest guy ever I have an IQ of
240 this the other thing so there was
all that kind of 240 that's what he
claims all right
I don't buy it all right not for one
second yeah also I could read when I was
two okay it's not really that big a deal
calm down so what no the same okay I say
early - yeah that's what I mean so it's
it's a lot of people can it's it's not
really the thing I mean they're not I
mean I could talk it would scare people
so little yeah I mean talking people
would be like Danny doc maybe I was just
short I don't know okay so as I said
this was founded in 1998 now by the time
2003 rolled around they claimed that
almost 4,000 people had taken their
classes including like a lot of kind of
big actors and businesspeople they even
said that Richard Branson took some
who's that big guy from virgin okay yeah
yeah he's like super famous he doesn't
like virgins because they're girls [ __ ]
well he said he didn't but they claimed
him anyway right now as I said even as
early as 2003 there were some people
that were like trying to call [ __ ]
on this [ __ ] right so in um so as I
said the the cult investigator whose
name is Rick Allen Ross he talks a lot
about Scientology and step two I've seen
him on lots of different documentaries
about this type of [ __ ] he actually
published some [ __ ] from their manual
like on his website or like describes
and stuff so they tried to sue him
because they're saying oh hey we have
non-disclosure agreement and we think
[ __ ] yes they do the same thing like
anybody that criticizes them or anybody
that publishes their super top secret
yeah like corporate sin like nobody
knows how to do all this stuff like to
make it like better there's you know how
to Ariel and you have to pay $25,000 to
learn how to do it it's like yeah no I
don't think so
so I mean nothing in there like I said
I've read some I'll run Harvard stuff
and I don't have to pay for it it's it's
nothing you haven't heard before it's
just with just like a little sprinkling
of crazy on top yeah it's not even whoo
it's not even whoo no no it's just you
know [ __ ] yeah it's like it's it's
not very basic stuff with a little bit
of [ __ ] don't know yeah that's right
it's not even like to the level of like
it's not even like Deepak Chopra level
[ __ ] where it's just rock deeper
he's just like Jannah meeting
stuff that sounds really profound you
don't yeah goddamnit Pookie way to move
and [ __ ] she's like she's gonna push
there there Deepak Chopra can say some
[ __ ] that was like mind-numbing because
but could the whoo the what it's like
the inside is outside and all the round
of us yeah yeah like that you know what
the inside is outside all around us just
you know just yeah it's like don't try
it and L RHD couldn't even come up with
some [ __ ] like that
now most of his [ __ ] was just warmed
over corporate yeah an Objectivist
object-- Objectivist kind of stuff but
with a little bit of crazy on top of it
cuz he was yeah and it's poorly written
it is it is morally written it is very
poorly you're definitely not in the
hands of an expert yeah yeah so for him
being like oh he's the most enlightened
smartest yada-yada it's like I'm not
seeing evidence of that I'm just
imaginary sorry imagine if like you're
your uncle Ted uncle Ted is trying to
spread wisdom to you and trying to
pretend to be a corporate guru yeah I
mean something like that yeah that's
exactly how it comes across and I
haven't read this douches stuff but it's
like I imagine it probably comes across
maybe it comes across like a little less
crazy because I don't think he was a
total whack job like Elmo Hubbard was he
was just a kind of regular con man so
maybe he could actually write something
slick and like I said [ __ ] corporate
speak doesn't even sound like English
anyway so because they use so much
jargon and like meaningless phrases and
[ __ ] I think I have to amend your words
though yeah because LRH wasn't really a
whack job what he was is he was just
kind of like an average Joe that could
spin a yarn and talking [ __ ] he's
the kind of guy that you'd run into on a
porch somewhere in Mississippi drunk off
his ass just telling you [ __ ] stories
you know I mean yeah telling you stories
about this time that he controlled the
weather yeah
about how the world worked no and how
the government works and how the banking
system works you know I mean he and this
is like a dude you know and it's and
it's like a dude from the 60s in s asipi
telling you this [ __ ] you know I mean
it's just not not really the person you
want to go to for anytime yeah yeah yeah
he's just like a random guy it's like
it's like you you're one crazy relative
exactly like they have like a few too
many and then they start ranting LRH
wasn't talented though l ron Hubbard was
a talented man spinning he's a talented
bullshitter [ __ ] [ __ ] and he
could [ __ ] tell you a tale and
everybody have a deadly people that
joined his cult we're just looking
mesmerised by the stories of [ __ ] you
know what battles happened on what stars
that he's showing you some stars an
alien you know yeah yeah I think that
was the strength of LRH was having him
there in person in the cult and him
telling you story some adjustment camera
of him telling you stories and end point
to the stars and they're out on the damn
ship what was the name of that damn ship
that they were on that the Freeman
they're on the freewinds and he's
telling you oh yeah that is Zeta
Reticuli - right there with this big old
flappy lips yeah yeah yeah and that's
what he did and that's what he did he
can make a system and [ __ ] but you know
as he died when he died it got handed
over to guys who you know like David
Miscavige that it's weird because and
turned it into something more aggressive
you know yeah and the thing about like
Scientology and this cults as well
because the guy that runs this [ __ ] key
through an area the guy that's going to
prison um
he seems and I'm not the only person to
say this because even the lady on ABC
that was doing this [ __ ] documentary
that was like interviewing people that
have left the cult we're like you know
you know not to blame the victim or
anything but it's like you know how
could you get second he seems charisma
free yeah like I said even the late
didn't use those words but that's what
she meant that's kind of the opposite of
LRH evidently I found him also charisma
free but evidently in the time poor
people that were there in Scientology in
the time that LRH was alive they were
having fun in the [ __ ] car
yeah all right that they liked it and
they were having fun and I guess that's
what the purpose of a cult is this is it
have fun you enjoy it you give them all
your body that doesn't sound fun to me
they liked it I want to not my tongue I
can have fun with it
it's less LARPing you know it's
live-action role play and that's I can't
have any fun of fun on her yeah but this
dude here managed to do so I got to get
off Scientology because I [ __ ] you
know well it's just going it's so
similar I mean the more I read about it
it's just like I'm like god damn it it's
like didn't anybody notice like this
similar it's like so they even use some
of the same words for Christ's sake
well it's probably probably what
happened is is that the guy that was in
charge of Nexium knew everything about
Scientology clearly exist he set it up
just like yeah it goes like that's a
winning strategy how can i how can i
really like they've made billions and
billions of dollars I need to do that
[ __ ] yeah I'll just rename it and I'll
get some [ __ ] out of it
no and that's really what courses that
was just you know the icing on the cake
because Scientologists aren't even
getting that I'm gonna go one better
that's probably exactly what he thought
that's exactly some get some [ __ ] out
of it and [ __ ] you know it's gonna be
kind of like BDSM we're gonna [ __ ]
you know I'm a brand and [ __ ] you
know it's like that yeah probably yeah
so yeah so as I said cuz the Scientology
the women that you're dealing with
they're basically like the foot can
something out of Lord of the Rings you
know they're like those little Hobbit
look at women you know the Bagginses
you know I mean that's that's who gets
is paying in Scientology either that
it's either like next like all girls
were all hot in Scientology it looks
like either they're either like the
Bagginses or they look like can I see
your manager yeah exactly exactly that
there's like no in-between it seems like
yes he's doing with a hotter younger
Bunch and he's gonna run through yeah he
did well some of them I like I said some
stayed in there til the end and they
like had to go on trial just right
alongside go [ __ ] a woman's mind up no
[ __ ] yeah
it's you know and depending on the woman
it's like not and some of them won't
like Sarah Edmondson like the woman that
I was listening to I was losing to that
Canadian broadcast the podcast about
with her
yeah and that was like an interview
there was like eight parts or something
like that and she was in it for 12 years
well I think so and then finally she was
just like what the [ __ ] am I even doing
is she got the hell out of there but
it's like yeah tell us more tell us how
this wind down but yeah so so in as far
back as 2003 people were calling this a
cult right so it's like Rick Allen Ross
is like published a bunch of stuff on
his web site that was like it's
supposedly their super secret training
methods or whatever and they tried to
sue him but the suits were dismissed now
then in October of 2003 Vanity Fair
wrote an article now the cult thought
that it was going to be some positive
fawning whatever and then Vanity Fair
was like nope and they like weird a
thing and they basically said that they
thought it was a cult and they or they
quoted people in there that thought it
was a cult and the cult got like super
super mad about it what's funny I don't
understand why they get mad over the
term cult everybody everybody gets upset
over the word cult a small religion is
always a cult and they don't get
offended over [ __ ] over the word over
the term religion yeah you know I mean
it's cuz I guess the negative comment it
kind of tail because incus I would if I
was gonna make a cult I would name it co
you like a Tom Kha the bootie warrior
Tom cult a bootie warrior you know is
some [ __ ] like that you don't mean in
that way you go into it knowing one that
and people call you a culture like well
yeah yeah yeah yeah you just have to
lean into like what the criticism
eventually it's gonna become a dominant
nomination and then a religion or a
religion and then a denomination of a
religion because I think the problem is
like when when you look like you're
trying so hard to like deny something
like you know what I mean it's like
people come out and go well I think it's
a cult and they're like well I'm gonna
sue but everybody's like well
everybody's gonna think well obviously
it's a cult yeah
they would be like nah man they wouldn't
care if they were just cool a lot of
things have the element of a religion or
a cult a lot of things do political
parties put certain political ideologies
have cult type but that's not that's not
really necessarily a bad thing I mean in
common parlance when you talk about a
cult it has to have specific aspects to
it to be a cult
I mean leader a bunch of followers right
yeah and it basically has to be
isolationist and the fact that it's
trying to let cut you off from friends
and family which this place did also
okay so you can only be surrounded with
people that think the same way as you do
has to be like a mill like a unit a
high-security right right right so it
has to have like a specific you know it
there's it means a specific thing okay
so it's not so much that they're just
like throwing that word around I mean
let's have a specific connotation that
that is negative I mean it's a negative
connotation because usually if you get
sucked into that [ __ ] it's like
somebody's got to go in there and save
your ass cuz before you get branded or
don't want it out though I know and that
was yeah they don't want out makes it
unless they're not getting the worst of
it or they think they deserve it I don't
really know I think the most successful
best cult in existence is probably the
cult of Reverend some somebody they're
still around right yeah they're around
and evidently they've making a lot of
money and the people with evidently and
like the cult you know and [ __ ]
reverend moon actually projects to go
out and fight communism so how bad could
it be you know about that yeah oh yeah
he without face communism all time he
brought down the [ __ ] evidently
brought down the Soviet Union you know
when you go outside of your body and do
[ __ ] outside of your body you can pretty
much take credit for anything yeah yes
that's some good thinking right there
man I have to start using that [ __ ] yeah
every time like something really awesome
happens to be like yeah those me I never
reject and I did that [ __ ] evidently
evidently from whatever
you know there's not you can't find much
about it but evidently Reverend mood was
okay he was alright he wasn't too bad
you know yeah I don't know Chris I don't
know a great deal about the Moonies it's
like pretty much the only thing I know
about them is like all the shit's what
it's like and that mass wedding thing
that they did but so okay so as I
mentioned before the two daughters like
the heirs of the Seagram liquor liquor
fortune had like given the cult all this
money and they're like super into them
and stuff now their dad um you know who
actually like bran Seagram liquor at the
time was seriously not happy about it
and he thought it was a cult as well so
he was like trying to get his now his
daughters are like old they're like
adults they're not kids or anything like
that so you know there was like a whole
bunch of thing there now they also I
think later on because I remember the
two the two sisters the the Seagram
sisters they're not named Seagram
they're named Brompton but they work at
like going into court because they
wanted to sue they they were actually
asking the Alba new County District
Attorney to sue like a bunch of the
critics of you know so they wanted to do
like this whole thing like Scientology
does where you know you criticize like
in any capacity then we're gonna sue you
into bankruptcy or we're gonna ruin your
life or whatever I don't think they do
like the [ __ ] like Scientology does like
they put up you know website saying
you're a child molester and stuff like
that you can hand out flyers if they do
that you guys yeah they hand out flyers
in the air bro you're saying yeah yeah
they kill your cats and dogs and like
you know give your neighbors Flyers
saying that you're like a sex offender
and ship MPI's to [ __ ] find out it
and go through your garbage yeah now
they now these people do go through
people's garbage because yeah because
Rick Allen Ross the cult investigator he
said they did like take all his garbage
okay like when they were trying to sue
virtually he's like yeah they actually
came from they come on my carpet she's
like they're like outside my house which
is like it was it was crazy but yeah so
so um
now before aliceandmac got in there like
I said she's kind of probably their most
famous member she got in because another
actress who was also on the same show
Smallville
named Kristin Kreuk now she got into it
in 2006 so she goes there she and she
like actually recruited Allison back
into it now Allison Maxie became like
they think that she might be kind of
like the shadow second or third in
command and like I said this is kind of
[ __ ] crazy and she admitted in court
evidently that she was the one that came
up with the branding idea mmm like for
branding the women because here's the
thing now okay now before I get into
that before I get into the good stuff I
have to say that here's another thing
that's like very much reminded me is
like Scientology
so the Bronfman sisters you know the
Seagram liquor people and vanguard or
wrong guard as I like to call him he
they started this [ __ ] thing with the
very Scientology esque name of the world
ethical foundations consortium that's
like some Scientology that's what I mean
it's just like this is killing me man
it's like it's like Scientology's little
brother or like them yeah perverted
little whenever you see these little
groups that have these names like this
they're just nothing but just all this
weird virtue coming out of that name
immediately cross that one off your list
don't trust that [ __ ] don't trust that
[ __ ] some unethical don't trust anything
yes Brooke does he made that [ __ ] up
yeah but yeah so they actually arranged
to have the [ __ ] Dalai Lama come and
to Albanian talk in like 2009 now for a
while he wasn't gonna come cuz there you
know there were even like some negative
[ __ ] going on before then they were like
maybe shouldn't do that [ __ ] but he did
end up going and there's like footage of
it cuz it was like some of it was in the
documentary that I saw so Dalai Lama
shows up and gives this cult all this
all his credit bill right and like yeah
and it's some of the dalai lama just by
[ __ ] just that's what i mean and it's
like now i wonder like he's over there
like [ __ ] kicking himself right yeah
vacating probably oh yeah but okay so
now we're gonna talk a little bit about
this supposedly an offshoot
it's not really but that's what that's
what Vanguard tried to claim yeah
there's a breakaway [ __ ] because yeah
because the most famous allegations
about this are the sex slaves okay I
mean obviously anything that has to do
with like sex cults is gonna be like big
news so now this story broke in 2017 in
the New York Times so this comes out
about the do s as I said it's you know
an acronym for a Latin term meaning
masters / slave women or something like
that now supposedly this was like an all
women group that was just run by the
ladies in nexium and they would recruit
other ladies and basically what they
would do is they would they would
approach you with this thing like oh
well we have this like women's
empowerment group or we have this one
that's just like all women and it's like
self-improvement and all this other kind
of stuff and they would get you to come
to this house and out and Albany and
then they would do like these weird like
eyes with some Eyes Wide Shut kind of
[ __ ] like you know what I mean
so Sarah Edmondson was talking about
this on the podcast she's like she gets
to this [ __ ] house and she's talking
to like this friend that she's known for
like for a really long time and she'd
kind of been in the group and taken some
classes and [ __ ] and she's like oh we
have this woman thing and it's really
cool and she's like okay whatever so she
comes to the house and she's like okay
well we have to do this like initiation
type of thing so it's like you have to
go upstairs and you have to take all
your clothes off and put on a blindfold
at which point I'd have been like newb
out yeah but you know what I mean I'd be
like yeah no I'm not doing that but
because it video tape oh well here's the
thing now she said this is another thing
they do and this is another very
Scientology thing they make you start
giving them what they call quote unquote
collateral yeah now at first she's like
at first it's just like innocuous [ __ ]
it's like oh I didn't go to the gym
today so you have to give me $10 it's
like it's like little [ __ ] like that but
then it kind of progressed to oh well
now I need pictures of your breasts now
I need pictures of your vagina now I
need like secrets about you
childhood abuse now I need this dunyah
like now they deal a secrets about so
now they have this dirt on you so you
can't so you can't leave so they do the
same kind of [ __ ] they have blackmail
material yeah basically because you
leaved and they go to all your relatives
and they [ __ ] scoff all that [ __ ] up
to yes or they go to the media or some
[ __ ] like that
yes yeah which I don't think that would
work on me either because one I haven't
done anything that I'm they would
looking down you [ __ ] nah they don't
have you Tom and Jenny sex tape I'd be
like whoo enjoy we're like look at the
size of that [ __ ] they can't shame me
that's what I mean you can't shame
people that have no shame we have no
shame can't [ __ ] somebody who roll you
over I get that [ __ ] on video and you'll
be up there testifying in front of the
judge and your whole family hanging your
head it's like because I say me I can't
think of anything I mean I can't think
of any deep dark secret that is like
because like I'll laugh anything off
well and also I'm like look seriously
I'm like the queen of TMI I don't think
there's any like dark secret about me
that people well here's a little thing
there's the thing you know I mean we're
not normal people we're in the goth
scene and we kind of grew up in Gotham
punk rock [ __ ] you don't mean so it's
kind of like an Oscar Wilde type
situation we just shrug off if you've
got skeletons in your closet even make a
living making them [ __ ] dance so any
kind of dirt you have on me I can flip
it around or [ __ ] make money off of
it or if I can get some kind of [ __ ]
you know made or people with just think
was funny or doesn't matter yeah you
keep that's why we were doing the show
some Scientology oh man what if they
come after something what could they do
to us
that's why I'm not worried about it what
can they do to us I'm just like when
actually I think it would be kind of
funny if they turned up like we're
sitting in our driveway and stuff like
man we could like throw bread crumbs and
stuff you'd be rad yeah I get so much
energy hey Tom Thank You shape but if
man put a website up there with like
pictures of my tits I don't care that
batter [ __ ] everybody
we just get more I mean on the birthday
see that the whole Scientology getting
dirt on you thing actually was a 1950's
ploy yeah that worked in the night boo
they're gay it's like no one cares a
very small Overton Window of
acceptability and anything outside well
[ __ ] man the United States [ __ ] its
goddamn it's like something down from
the Roman Roman Imperial era you know I
mean [ __ ] you know you
everything's if everything's [ __ ] out
there now and that's nothing literally I
don't think there's I mean and and I've
had you know some of our friends that
have told me some like pretty you know
fairly shocking things about like their
past or what they've done and stuff like
that but like I said we've enough that's
what I mean it would just roll with it
it's like very very unless somebody told
me they were a serial killer or
something like that that's about all
that would shock me is like that's
pretty much the only thing no I don't
think there's anything else again sharp
me and I really can't think of anything
that anyone could expose about me or you
that would like ruin our lives or like
ruin our career or life because if they
expose anything about me it would just
increase my notoriety yeah that's what I
am and it's like you know yeah anything
nice in resolume so I told my mom that
show yeah you know it's like so I don't
know I it's what these cults are looking
for or not people like me and you so
yeah like I said they're shameless so it
wouldn't matter
they're if you ask me I think like super
kind of yuppies they're the kind of
nerds and they're they're LARPing and
they look for people to have money
people that are a status seekers and
they want conventional status they want
approval from corporate entities and I
mean so I mean that's the thing like
even if you're in the entertainment
industry I mean maybe a long time ago
like if it came out that oh you know you
were having an affair or you were gay or
something like that or you just like a
bottle up that woman's couch look at
verses name what was
guy's name who did that and that cost
him that back in the 20s that cost him
his [ __ ] career Oh was that Fatty
Arbuckle Fatty Arbuckle yeah well well
also that woman died in his hotel room
yeah but they never really did say
evidently I've heard that it really
wasn't his fault I think it was an
accident I don't really think I mean I
don't he didn't mean to kill I think I
don't was saying drugs and alcohol
related I think yeah Oh d-don't
something well and plus I think he was
having sex with her and he was a lot
bigger than her because you know yeah
that didn't kill her though I think she
died from you there were plenty of drugs
available yeah kill you well yeah then I
think you're up there taking drugs yeah
I like cocaine or heroin but yeah so I I
feel like that's I thought it wasn't
heroin in the twenties it would have
been morphine yeah I think I don't think
heroin exists into the twenties or it
did but it was under a different animal
I don't think it existed in the toys any
that came later but I feel like that I
mean that's something that I just really
don't think that would ruin your career
nowadays I just really don't think
especially especially if somebody dug up
some dirt on you and then you just
leaned into it yeah like if you just
came on the talk shows like yeah that's
it dad they never won't forget about
that gets into the news [ __ ] that's
going on now the only thing that could
hurt you is like what's going on with
this teen silence yeah underage if you
yeah well they're kids and also if
you're a [ __ ] rapist - that's not
good yeah but I'm talking about like
consensual [ __ ] right I'm talking about
like back in the old days you know they
could have dirt on you because like oh
we know you're gay or we know that
you're having an affair we know this is
that the other whereas like if something
like that came out nowadays no one would
care yeah you know what I mean yeah if
you're a rapist like I'm not talking
about criminal Shelia slee actually I
was remember something about like CIA
and intelligence agencies used to like
to [ __ ] find out if guys were
cheating on their wives and they would
try to use that as leverage to get to
give up secrets you know foreign spies
and [ __ ] like that yeah and they were
using [ __ ] women to try to entrap
guys
yeah extramarital sex and it turned out
that the results war is that that was
ineffective yeah that
you know I mean that extramarital
affairs were ineffective [ __ ] to get
guys to give up secrets yeah they found
out later than what you needed does you
need is something like underage underage
girls well yeah because something better
affairs it's you know it's not good but
it's like it's so common it's common and
then women tolerated a lot of times
because these are older couples and for
all you know the husband and wife maybe
haven't been together in years they
might be you know I mean a lot of times
that the the relationships might be kind
of just for for the kids anyway
especially back in the days that they're
talking about but talk about back in the
50s yeah fifties in the 60s you know
what I mean so extra term aryl
extramarital affairs were not effective
leverage yeah like even then even those
days no and less now probably less now
because like I said it's you know like I
said it's not good but it's like it's so
common a guy won't give up a [ __ ]
state secret because he cheated on his
wife yeah just tell his wife says hey
honey this mistakes were made
yeah you loved her her tits were super
yeah she had a cruise like Tom Cruise oh
she's going like well just describe her
to take me through this do this I mean
it's not the world as it seems all the
time yeah so so the thing about this was
that they would kind of build up so
they'd have this collateral about them
where it's like they had like some dark
secrets from their childhood they said
dark secrets about [ __ ] that they had
done and also they have like a bunch of
naked pictures of them like naked videos
of them and stuff like that much like
Scientology does so they would use that
as collateral now as I said Sarah
Edmondson he was talking on this
documentary about what she went through
so she's like she goes there she's like
they tell her and it wasn't just her it
was like a couple other women too and
it's like they tell her to like take off
your
closed put your put your you know
blindfold on and they said that they
were going to just oh we're gonna give
you like a little tattoo like to like
commemorate your you know commitment to
the cause or whatever the [ __ ] they said
and then they bring out a cauterizing
gun and they branded them and when they
branded them and you can see there's
I'll put a picture of it in the video
there's a picture of her brand and like
some other people have had them as well
and they said that it's oh it's just
like this really cool Latin symbol but
if you look at it it's actually um Ken
Ranieri Vanguard Vanguard and Alison
Mac's initials like it's a design make a
brand initials into it into her yeah and
she was like super rad shoe I mean she
even said like on the [ __ ]
documentary she's like I'm not cattle
she's like don't [ __ ] it cuz she didn't
know I mean she know what they were
gonna do they said oh we'll give you a
little tattoos like it'll show like your
commitment that [ __ ] her group and said
oh yeah
she said on the documentary she said it
was worse than childbirth Dan and that's
like the other woman on there was like
are you [ __ ] me
like she didn't say that no like that's
what she meant and like she's like yeah
seriously she's like because it took a
long time it took like already it was
already ran they [ __ ] know it was a
little cauterizing guy okay they wrote
it alright she's like it took like 30 to
45 minutes yeah she's like it was just
like this burning like I think just like
past it she's like it was horrible she
was like it's the worst pain I've ever
experienced yeah so they did that and
she's like and she's like and I could
see them and there were other women like
holding them down Dan like well this was
happening yeah what the [ __ ]
girls yeah well god damage so what were
they thinking ah I don't even know well
get to the next well no I'm just saying
like I'm saying that like now of a
sudden I'm [ __ ] curious and what the
what these [ __ ] take it well and
that's what like I think the lady that
hosted the the ABC they like the 20/20
program yeah she didn't know what they
were thinking either she's like
interviewing this woman like I said she
was like talking to talking about this
[ __ ] she's like why do you just run out
the door why do you just and like I said
I hate to blame the victim but I
she's like look at this point I had been
in this group for such a long time I
knew all these people they were my
friends at this point they had kind of
cut her off from like family and friends
without home really realizing it yeah
it's like it's kind of like you know
they kind of slowly um you know
disassociate you from your outside
influences which is another thing that
Scientology does as well um actually all
cults pretty much all cults do that
because they just they want this echo
chamber where you can only like hear the
message of the cult you don't want any
outside influence come down I don't
think this is a good idea but um yeah so
she's like she's like I thought it was
[ __ ] up but you know she's like I'd
been in it so long I'd spent so much
money on it it's like you know these
were my friends and it's like a
nightclub well and she and she kind of
um and the way when she was talking I
kind of got this whole thing about you
know Ken Ranieri in his whole like
negging of like the women in the cult
she's like you know I had been in the
cult long enough to have internalized
the message that you know I'm a woman
therefore I'm weaker I'm you know I I'm
bad so I need to get over that so I kind
of felt like if I did this it would make
me better it would make me tougher make
me not like that so where most of the
most of the people that applied or
answered the sculptor most of them are
women um I don't know about that but I
think most of the more famous ones were
women just because they were famous
actresses they picked on the women once
women came in yeah decided he's gonna
start grooming them because yeah that's
definitely what he did and and I'm not
saying like yeah he had like a harem
pretty much like 11 12 women um he also
one of the charges against him that I
believe he I think he was found guilty
of all charges as far as I know of this
back in June 2019 one of them was also
against an underage girl this is a
fifteen-year-old which was the first one
that he was like grooming this I was
gonna get about 30 years for this [ __ ] I
hope so like I said 15 to life that's
what they're talking about she'll get 30
that well that made me happy cuz he
probably [ __ ] dead
but yes get out early um I don't know it
just seems like this is the kind of
thing like I said his whole the whole
thing about this I mean the women's
group what he said initially like when
the rumors about the whole sex slave
thing started circulating like he was
like oh that das thing you know that's
nothing to do with me I don't run that
that's like the ladies as a thing but
aside from this 15 year-old girl was
this rape or was this consensual with
all the other ones well see he tried to
argue it was consensual but what the
other ones say I see I don't know if it
is because the women that he had sex
with that he was keeping his sex slaves
yeah
they were basically he had blackmail
material on right but they wouldn't like
come and go and go out and go to their
normal jobs and then come back to where
I don't know no because a lot of them
and aliceandmac in particular because
like I said she was like a fairly famous
actress she'd been on Smallville and
stuff now when that show wrapped up in
2011 she basically like quit acting and
moved to Albany New York to be in the
cult like to live within the cult [ __ ]
so some of them were doing that and wait
did they make money for the call you
know what I don't know like I don't know
if they were doing that or if he was
like doing some other cuz he they were
making a lot of money like with the
courses okay so the courses were making
enough money to support yeah because
like I said this one course like one of
these intensive Zoar whatever that was
like you know 14-hour days or whatever
is like twenty five thousand dollars
like twenty five to fifty thousand
suckers you think that are they're just
super [ __ ] rich wow I sure wish I had
fifty thousand dollars I could live for
like ten years on that show 5050 I could
live for maybe two I could live for it
so one of these courses and you're
supposed to toughen up some kind of an
executive is that what this is all about
or something or like making skills make
them better it [ __ ] make them sound
awful hokey to me I don't really get
with it what the goal was it must be
something like basic training where are
you good in there you kind of [ __ ]
yeah I mean you kind of [ __ ] it
into being tougher and more intense and
then you let him go back into their
[ __ ] the companies where they came
from and they're evidently got some swag
after all that and like I said a lot of
them said that it did maybe ah to get in
this [ __ ] business
oh don't you saw a [ __ ] haze the [ __ ]
out of a [ __ ] I'll make you
tough as [ __ ] I'm done
you made $25,000 Tom's cold I'll do it
with you see I don't believe in this you
tell somebody to do something type of
deal that's not it's not leadership if
you tell somebody deuce do something
you're gonna do it with them well you
don't make fair things that's how you do
it that's how you get your cred you
can't just tell somebody to do something
you do with them well yeah I would have
a lot more respect for ya all of these
corporate douches if like right so
whatever I do to you I'm gonna do with
I'm gonna do right with you see even
even if it's bootie warrior and a bootie
warrior in both directions on both sides
of two bootie warriors he's an equal
opportunity opportunity man got desires
if you don't understand it look up go on
go on
he's giving them a bug go on go on
[ __ ] YouTube and look up fleece
Johnson fleece Johnson booty warrior is
it fleece like like a fleece oh yeah
yeah fleece jacket fleece Johnson booty
warrior and you will understand
everything now I kind of want to I meant
to watch it and I forgot about it you
never saw it no oh [ __ ]
well you gonna show it to me right now
no no the prison thing okay yeah I
wouldn't understand you in those damn
[Laughter]
all right
so okay so another actress that was in
that was kind of in it for a little
while
Catherine Oxenberg who is very famous in
the 1980s because she was on dynasty now
her and her daughter her daughter India
who was on some
like teen talk show or something like
that and they went to some classes
together and then Catherine Oxenberg the
older one she was just kind of like nah
not for me but the daughter stayed in it
so now like Catherine Oxenberg is like
oh no she wrote a [ __ ] book she's on
all the goddamn documentaries and stuff
saying for her daughter get the [ __ ] out
of there and apparently I don't get the
[ __ ] out of there but now it's maybe she
well now I don't know since everybody's
been [ __ ] convicted
although here's the thing I feel like
now they're talking about how nexium is
like oh it started collapsing like when
everybody got like [ __ ] indicted and
everything but I kind of feel like and
this happens with Scientology some too
is that every time somebody brings a
lawsuit against them or every time like
Leah Remini comes out with like the
documentary or whatever I feel like
there's a percentage of them that are
just gonna like dig their heels in
because they feel like they're being
persecuted and there is nothing more
powerful than feeling like you're being
persecuted especially if you're not
really being person yeah but this cult
wasn't very old
Scientology's a lot older and there are
people that were born into it so it's a
different effect this one wasn't around
for very long usually what happens is a
cult never really disappears just kind
of dwindles down and gets smaller and
smaller before it just takes another
form and then it turns into another call
so that's usually what and then
sometimes you get like a hundred people
living in a little commune somewhere
right now something that I forgot to
mention when I was talking about this
[ __ ] group was that not only was
there this whole das thing that was
supposedly like the sex slave whatnot
but there was also a women's group
called Janis and then there was also
like a male-only group that was called
the Society of protectors or some [ __ ]
like that well like I said this was a
very patriarchal kind of like dudes that
the protectors women are the stupid
idiots that have to be told what to do
type of thing like he very much had that
view of women like that's what women
were supposed to do they were supposed
to just be the helpers and they
weren't as good they had to be protected
and blah blah blah and they had all
these psychological issues that needed
to be fixed so that's why now but what I
was saying about das was that he
initially said when like I said the
whole sex slave element was starting to
like rumors about that we're starting to
swirl around you know Vanguard said that
oh I don't have anything to do with that
he even wrote that [ __ ] on his website
it might still be there like I think
it's probably like [ __ ] archived at
this point cuz I don't know if their
website still alive or not but um you
can go to like the Wayback Machine and
check it out but um yeah so he's like I
didn't have anything to do with that
blah blah blah but then when you know
when he was on the stand on the trial
he's like yeah I was in charge of that
so he did actually admit that even
though he's pleading not guilty but like
I said all the women that were like you
know on trial next to him did actually
plead guilty because I guess they have
some shame you are right
yeah she's wrong gantry so okay so in
2018 so this is like you know fairly
recent so aliceandmac was actually
arrested and she was indicted also now
as I said Mark Renier was arrested at
his big old palatial mansion in Porto
Bay are to Mexico where I don't know if
he thought cuz the federales arrested
him I don't know if like he thought he
was gonna like go to Mexico and
everybody's just gonna like get away
with it cuz he wasn't in the US anymore
yeah that didn't work out
Mexican government didn't like you
stupid ass either yeah jimmy hendrix
lyrics makes a cool way yes yes so he's
living there was like essentially twelve
sex slaves and so yeah so there's
actually if you watch the 20/20
documentary they have like a little bit
of a footage of them arresting him like
the theater Ollie's coming and there's
what looks like footage of Alison Mac
you know the actress in the thing like
looking all like with the folk like as
he's bidding put getting put in the car
and she looks like super skinny now they
said that that happened a lot with a lot
of the women that were in das I don't
know if it was because they told him
they were Fatso's or if they weren't
feeding them or what they were doing but
all of them looked like really it's my
understanding it's my understanding that
he told them that they should always
certainly
that sounds like that's right he gave
each one of them a certain way to meet
he likes skinny girls evidently so yeah
she looked like yeah too skinny
I mean you know not judging but I'm just
saying she looked skinnier than she uh
yeah so she got arrested also what the
hell is that cat and she actually did
confess that she had you know recruited
women into this into das that she had
coerced them into getting brands that
she had coerced them into having sex
with [ __ ] Vanguard who if you see
pictures there's just one picture I'm
not gonna put in the video because it's
too [ __ ] gross but like the one they
showed on the [ __ ] 20/20 show was like
him and he's like laying back on a bed
like [ __ ] ron jeremy or some [ __ ]
like with his hands behind his head like
on this green like ugly green sheets or
whatever yeah dude is so [ __ ] furry
yeah like he's got chest hair like an
easy-fit I haven't seen a guy um he's
average size but he's like looking
they're like he's like [ __ ] sex God
of the world's like I'm Vanguard come
you know get on this I'm like no thank
you no thank you but you know it's like
not even I'd rather know were they sex
slaves or were they willing was it like
a harem and they were [ __ ]
worshipping this guy I really don't feel
like because it's kind of creepy because
there's there's this one video and they
showed like little parts of it in the
twenty20 documentaries well we're
aliceandmac was like interviewing him
now she was obviously I feel like a lot
of them were kind of brainwashed because
some of them like I said it started
slowly yeah like this what it wasn't a
kind of thing where you just like walked
in for a class and everybody's like hey
take your clothes off we're gonna brand
your vagina it took like a long time to
get to that point and and I should note
too much like Scientology some people
that have tried to like undercover like
go in and take classes like to write
about the [ __ ] they won't let
you have to be invited you have to have
an invite to take a class you can't just
like walk in off the street so it's not
like open to the public which again
that's kind of a red flag and
Scientology does that as well right if
you want to walk into one of their orgs
and active up and act like the angry gay
Pope like like oh I'm so interested in
this set in the other but as soon as
they know like who you are you don't
really want to do it or you want
information about that they want to then
they'll be super cagey and then they'll
try to get rid of you and that's
essentially what happened in this case
right so yeah I'm getting it in my mind
that these more sex slaves per se what
they were is they were just [ __ ] kind
of brainwashed cult members yeah we're
having sex with this guy for what for
what they thought was religious purposes
I feel like I'm or feel like the ones
that got out and that that were
interviewed they said they felt like
they didn't have a choice okay because
they're like one we'd been in so long
that we were so you know he takes pretty
much all of your self-esteem away your
self identity away but also he had all
this like blackmail [ __ ] on you but then
you wonder how will that hold up in
court how will the court interpret that
and I think I don't know if it did the
courts interpret that as rape um I don't
know if they called it that exactly but
he did get I can't remember though there
was like a huge list of like all the
[ __ ] charges that he had against him
but it was basically kind of like a that
kind of situation because they didn't
call it rape but it was a situation
where he had so much control over you to
thank you or something
that's what I mean it was more coerced
because you can rape through coercion as
well I mean obviously yeah I don't know
how it works in court but I'll tell you
one thing I mean you could go to like
it's not you can go to Scientology's
what's a gold base yeah freakin where
they have that all out there in the
mountains and [ __ ] they have a
Scientology prison there which is not
really a president's all the executives
that are being punished and they're in
those damn trailers they got bars on the
windows of the trailers and some of them
have been in there for nearly a decade
in those damn trailers yeah
okay that's a [ __ ] long sentence yeah
well you could send the FBI in there all
right to break them out of that prison
and they wouldn't leave yeah they go no
I'm here because I deserve to be here
this is my religion and this I'm paying
religious penance you know I mean so
it's wrong the feds don't really know
quite what to do with well it's fo I'm
lying because it's like how much that
that's the thing it's like if somebody
if somebody is drawn into a cult at a
very vulnerable point in their lives say
maybe there's like a 19 year old girl
she's just gone through like some
terrible trauma or some [ __ ] like that
she gets sucked into this [ __ ] and then
she's in it for several years and she's
isolated from her family she's isolated
for refresh she's isolated from the
outside world comes you only world dish
and it becomes the only thing that she
knows does she really have free will
anymore that's kind of I don't know I
don't you know what I mean it's like it
depends on the person I guess I must say
it's a great area I'm gonna say no but
the law isn't gonna see it that way
because well I feel like it well I feel
like that it'll be like extenuating
circumstances I feel like ever every
case will probably be different in the
United States there's religions they're
kind of enshrined to freedom the freedom
of religion is kind of enshrined so you
could say well this is a religious act
so therefore its constitutional it's
weird in the United States that's what I
mean and this is like it I don't know if
I'm by into the into this because these
aren't traditional religions I don't
know they should really have the same
kind of protections if you asked me I
don't know my opinion I mean I don't
think they should have protections any
more than anybody else anybody else I
mean I don't think like if you want to
do illegal [ __ ] that for anyone else
would be illegal then I don't think you
should be used to be in the 70s though
it wasn't that way there were an actual
pedophile churches that have protections
back in the 70s that's what I mean see
no I don't think they do that anymore
no it would but that was the
interpretation of it
then that's what I mean if your church
has some [ __ ] that's like I feel like
pedophilia yeah or you know animal
cruelty or something like that that is
illegal for everyone else
then it's illegal for you to your
religion is not an excuse that's why I
don't like that like that's why I don't
like this whole thing we're you know
we're like parents are like well we
didn't take our kids to the doctor
because we don't believe in doctors cuz
blah blah blah
and like we tried to exercise them and
then like we suffocated them to death or
we starve them to death or whatever it's
they need to go to jail I think so too
they need to go to jail that kind of
think that's not an excuse if I did that
to a kid and I didn't have that excuse I
would go to jail and so should you
religion is an excuse that's what I mean
and and then there are certain things
that have to be [ __ ] stamped out in a
religious what are you gonna say well
our religion believes in human sacrifice
that's what I mean where does it where
does it end where does it end
like I I don't have a problem if what
you're doing doesn't affect other people
negatively you know what I mean like
I've seen like some religions it's like
oh we want to take peyote I don't have a
problem with that
some religious won't let people leave I
don't believe in that no yeah yeah that
I don't believe in that either because
like I said that that whole thing where
it's like that to me that constitutes
kidnapping yeah because you're
preventing a person from freely leaving
the premises you know what I mean cuz
you know we're we saw some documentary
the other day about [ __ ] one of the
Mormons it was Mormons or it was what it
was one of the Mormon cults like Mormon
off she works or something like that the
girls leave and they're like the girls
couldn't leave and [ __ ] like that and
I'm pregnant underage actually that no
way I don't give a [ __ ] what your
religion says that would be illegal for
anyone else therefore it should also be
illegal for you yeah I think all
religions should apply just not just not
just Mormons all religions well yeah
like yeah well like I said anything that
would be illegal for a purse for a
non-religious person it should also be
illegal so - I don't think you should
get any special
secular society you know demean and
[ __ ] secular law comes before all
these religious laws because in a
secular society we we know that release
religions are [ __ ] no matter how
much these people think they're real
they're not really real and you know I'm
gonna say it's Judaism Christianity
Islam even Buddhism they're not real
really yeah I mean you can't violate the
law just because you belong to those
yeah I agree with that like I said it's
you shouldn't get special consideration
you shouldn't get special honestly I'm
gonna even say I don't even like that
they get tax-exempt status I don't like
that it's kind of odd it's weird I like
I understand the history of it I know
where it comes from and stuff but I
think that's about time too because
corporations get involved in it big
money gets involved in that they [ __ ]
abused it well yeah no that is gone no I
know because well what a lot of churches
will do and I've seen a lot of them do
this even where I grew up and stuff like
that is they will like yeah it's like
they'll open up other businesses yeah
like one church that was near where I
grew up they opened this massive [ __ ]
like an old-age home you know what I
mean like it was apartments and stuff
and it's like they this huge like
massive thing of land and because it was
like church-affiliated they didn't have
to pay taxes on it
so even though it was a business and
they were making a lot of money the only
thing that they're doing either a
[ __ ] can merge up with un-un NGOs and
do things for them that I believe well
like I said anytime they get you know it
as long as they're doing stuff I don't
care what people believe I really don't
as long as they're not infringing on
other people's [ __ ] you know what I mean
that's all so that's what I mean so and
but that's why I'm kind of fascinated by
talking about cults because it's such
it's like in a lot of ways these people
got into it willingly I mean you could
say like I said these women that got
into nexium for example they willingly
went to these classes they willingly
paid for these classes you know they
sure it you know ratcheted up to a point
where they weren't really comfortable
with it anymore
they're still branding them and raping
them basically right but once it gets to
that point it's like once it got to that
point they had been in it so long that
like I said I would argue that I don't
know if they really have all their free
will intact anymore
because they've been so because the
whole thing of a cult within a process
of what's got institutionalization right
exactly
so I fee and that's something that all
of cults do Scientology does this every
cult I've ever heard of does this they
isolate you from friends and family they
isolate you from outside influences they
basically make it seem like we have this
one leader he is infallible if you
question anything he says then you will
be punished or you're wrong
you know they Gaslight you they do all
this other [ __ ] and if that is done to
you for a long enough time I would argue
that you don't really have all your
faculties about you anymore and if this
[ __ ] kind of happens you I don't think
at that point you can consent anymore
yeah really those abuses have happened
in any culture every kind of church also
yeah and every kind of organizations
[ __ ] like that even sports organizations
weird [ __ ] it does seem like once once
an organization of any type like gets to
any type of users eyes or to [ __ ] with
people then it gets to yeah and it's a
shame but but and it's a shame that
people will take advantage of it like
this [ __ ] douche did yeah but he's
going to prison so yeah I think what
they need is and you start arming people
with the knowledge that they need in
order to [ __ ] see what these things
are understand what these things are
when they [ __ ] see them but it's hard
to believe that someone can be sucked
into something like this and not know
that's what kind of bothers me because
it's like this is so I mean when I was
reading about this I'm like god that
sounds just like Scientology I mean
pretty much everything about this sounds
exactly like Scientology and I would
have thought that by now I mean other
than the people that are still in this
[ __ ] um I would have thought that by now
everybody knew that what Scientology was
up to and like what they were doing what
methods they were using I had thought
that was pretty well like integrated
into culture but it seems that people
are still falling for something that is
essential
exactly the same yeah you know what I
mean and like I said I'm not gonna [ __ ]
on people because I know that people
like have and like I said there's
nothing wrong with like wanting to
improve your life but a quota it so I'm
gonna take a business course and then
I'll be better like there's nothing
wrong with that the funny thing about
Scientology is that Scientology no
longer needs to grow by getting new
members it doesn't have to proselytize
anymore it's big enough to where it can
actually grow just by the reproduction
of its own members they have children
now it's funny that's what scares me
yeah they don't have you guys read the
[ __ ] yeah read that book called
beyond belief about that girl that got
out she was born into it yeah and then
she got the [ __ ] out when she was older
it is horrifying yeah horrifying they
don't need to get any outside blood
anymore really although they are doing
if they're mostly preying on people in
Central and South America that don't
know any better but I would think
Internet is slowly reaching everywhere
eventually everyone will know but it's
funny cuz it well then they'll just
change the [ __ ] name to something
else because they've already started
doing that because when I worked at a
print shop here there is um something
here I wouldn't call it a church
necessarily but it's like a little
organization I can't wear what the name
of it is but we used to do like some
print jobs for them pretty sure that was
a Scientology front yeah it's funny but
it's called something different and they
don't say nothing about Scientology on
any of their [ __ ] they're very careful
not to do that but I'm pretty sure like
I was reading their stuff I'm like hmm
yeah I think that's well there are also
some Scientology knock-offs
yeah breakaways around here what's funny
is that if you look at Scientology now I
mean I've been seeing videos posted by
Darth Zander he's out there protesting
and taking photos of people coming out
of Scientology headquarters down there
it outside outside of [ __ ] Law Center
Hollywood what's that big big blue yeah
coming out of big blue and everything
which is a big blue building that they
have yeah
Scientology has slowly become Hispanic
yeah well that look at Allah that's the
new audience they're targeting yeah
because it's not the it's not the the
people who are paying though it's all
the
laughs yeah which are basically the
slaves you come in you don't well yeah
they don't hate you you don't pay you
but you get free food and lodging and
they work you to death and it's kind of
like it's a Co yeah and it's all
Hispanic now it's [ __ ] I guess they
[ __ ] didn't have what it did you know
I guess they just say hey come to the
United States you know join the cult and
come the United States [ __ ] you don't
have to worry about anything the next
thing you know they're done their work
over the cove that I nexium did that as
well yeah they had some like
undocumented people and they would like
hide them but then they would like steal
their identities and like right there
Ronnie and [ __ ] like that so you know
keep it classy nexium that's how you do
but yeah I was I was reading like some
of the names of their [ __ ] courses
and it's like so Scientology as Dracula
and his ghouls as people perfect world
the heroic struggle that kind of [ __ ]
and like I said even like people that
like you know talk [ __ ] about them are
called suppressives or they're called
Luciferians which is pretty awesome yeah
so yeah I don't really know man it's
like this kind of [ __ ] I don't know I'm
never getting involved in this kind of
crap I don't I really don't see I mean I
know everybody says that but I really
don't see any conceivable way that I
could get mixed up with anything like
because one I'm not a joiner I hate
people
I don't like want to do anything with
people yeah any time people ask me to do
something I'm just like no I don't want
to so it's like I can't see any what's
go to this group and like
self-improvement I'd be like no thanks
I'm just gonna stay home and drink if
it's all the same to you it's a lot
safer all right so let's wrap up this
show which was kind of marginally about
the hold on you gonna wrap it up yeah
this is something that I wanted to say
but what you said I thought you were
done you know I'm like oh you're under
there doing you're not done with it
waving around okay basically how this
relates to this whole Q thing that I was
talking about is that Q which I don't
know if this is the real phenomena or
not they're saying that
Epstein's island was a situation kind of
like nexium okay where it was a call a
sex cult type situation there there was
a temple up there actually I thought
they said in drones over there to go
look at it and that this cult was
actually kind of backed it was funded by
the CIA and what it did was and this is
true he was coming down here to Florida
and getting these underage girls that
were you know 16 17 from the trailer
parks neighbor taking him up to this
island and what he would do is he would
take world leaders to this island to
have sex with these girls and get it all
on video and use it as dirt the same way
Scientology uses dirt on people so the
CIA could control foreign operatives and
people here in the United States and
that queue is say that the Jeffrey
Epstein [ __ ] situation was a
situation similar to this I don't know
if it's true but that's just what it
says I don't know I haven't heard that
well that's what the only key only this
cue thing and I'm trying to figure out
this cue thing it I don't know if this
source is that this information is
actually coming from this source called
cue or if this thing called cue is
getting this from [ __ ] public sources
and you know what I mean
and regurgitating it as its own the
things that this Q source seems to talk
about seems to eventually mostly come
true some of the [ __ ] didn't come true
but I haven't figured out whether or not
if it's this is a real source or not
it's definitely more than one person
they're posting it on a place called
8chan everybody knows what a chan is
yeah no I'm telling you that you know
what a Chan is yeah okay posting it on a
channel everybody knows what it's and
then they got a bunch of other people in
turn oh and goes there but then they got
youtubers and other people trying to
[ __ ] do their own shows based on
these posts and to me it kind of reads
like tea leaves I don't think there's
much I don't think there's much
you know I think it's [ __ ] you think
it's [ __ ] yeah but I'm still looking
nothing good ever comes out of a chin
you're not I mean it is interesting what
this what this source is saying I don't
know man I just like I don't cuz here's
the thing cults or cults they all
operate the same exact way dudes are not
that imaginative um so any dude that
starts a sex cult it's gonna go down
pretty much the same way because that's
just how it goes and like I said so
this cult comes across very much like me
to me like Scientology like every other
cult so I don't know if there's any
relationship between those two things
it's like I don't know I didn't see no
one was talking about that oh I was
looking at this Epstein's Island videos
of the drone footage drones flying over
it have I showed it to you no I'll show
it to you he's got a temple on there and
everything it's a pretty interesting
Island emits kind of cheap looking in
some ways but it is there and it is his
Island this source is saying that what M
Steen had going on there was something
kinda like a kind of like the nexium
cult it's just that he was being funded
by the CIA as a CIA operative to get
world leaders and world leaders did fly
down there that is that is proved you
know a lot of this shit's been
documented from flight records that they
were going to this island and evidently
to have sex with his underage girls and
he was bugging it you know with cameras
and and [ __ ] microphones to get dirt
on the world's on world's leaders so
they could manipulate them to get to get
them to do what they wanted to do just
like in the same way they were using
dirt on the you know the man yeah here
so I've just I'm just interested to see
how it's gonna go I'm not gonna discount
it maybe it's possible yeah I mean it's
possible that's like some of the CIA
would do I don't know you would know
about her well I was just I know good I
just researched this yeah anything I
have seen as I know about FC's Island
that's what I mean there was nothing
about that okay it's related so I don't
know okay so um yeah so Oh
the thing I was gonna mention to that
was also kind of similar Scientology was
that whenever it was this douchebags
birthday they would have Vanguard week
cuz it had a whole week of like birthday
celebrations and everybody had to like
kiss his ass and all this that also I
forgot to mention this this is my
favorite thing and I was like oh I have
to mention this I was like at the bottom
of my notes so apparently when like some
of the higher-ups and the nexium kind of
inner circle type of thing so they
supposedly told them that like in past
lives
they were high-ranking Nazis yeah yeah
yeah heard about that so apparently a
Saltzman Nancy Saltzman was apparently
the reincarnation of Hitler so even
though she's Jewish there's that yeah my
name is that work hey man so [ __ ] okay
yeah I like I like read that and I was
like wait what okay they're gonna do
they're gonna do what Scientology says
gonna say well we're many different
people along along the whole track so we
were all Nazis it's like is that how
should I feel about that what dick what
he's gonna say is that you're a Jew now
but in another life you were Nazi that's
what they gonna say that's the dumbest
[ __ ] ever this is the dumbest [ __ ] ever
seriously I was like I'm fascinated by
this [ __ ] but this is the dumbest [ __ ] I
know and it would like believe this
dumbest [ __ ] [ __ ] remember I remember
they all had kind of Nazi names and
different positive
of the Third Reich well they all thought
they were reincarnated Nazi yeah they
all thought the it was like everyone
liked the vehicle anyway yeah the [ __ ]
is the matter with you it was a [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] multi-dimensional Nazi
[ __ ] space cult with Jewish members
yeah I don't get it I don't get any of
this I'm just telling you right now they
were jealous jealous
they were bunch of Jewish people a bunch
of money jealous of the Nazis I guess
[ __ ] in a cult
that's messed up seriously yeah
seriously get some real therapy it's
like you you don't need to pay seventy
five hundred dollars to this [ __ ]
douche bag like [ __ ] Vanguard
damnit but it's now better like now I'm
gonna be September 25th it's supposed to
be his like hearing for his like his
sentencing that's the day before my
birthday so that would be a birth early
birthday present hopefully his prison
for a long time because like I said I
saw interviews with this dude like on
the interviews and seven life on the
documentaries and stuff and I'm just
like oh my God if I could punch that
well the guys that are the leaders of
these operations actually know the
masterminds of these operations they're
intelligent guys but they're mostly just
making [ __ ] up as they go along I feel
we're gonna take advantage of [ __ ] I
don't know maybe said I don't know if
it's I don't know if it's just me or
some old or what it is I just I don't
have patience if you don't have patience
you know she's gotta [ __ ] anymore it's
like you know I see this dude on TV like
seriously he was on there for like five
seconds and I was like nope enough for
that ladies and gentlemen I would like
to say that Jenny doesn't have patience
I don't [ __ ] not anymore okay I'm
sitting literally just like [ __ ] just
like in lethal weapon it's like I'm too
old I'm with Danny Glover right you're
with Danny Glover okay right there I'm
too old for this [ __ ] all right
oh now I'm allowed to so now I'm allowed
to shut it down didn't have to go off on
this well I I've said what I had to say
okay okay you you always say what you
need to say I thought you got something
to say say it say it I'm not saying
anything you just want the show to be no
one's stopping you alright so that was
episode 156 which is kind of Marvin
marginally about the nexium cult uh I
hope you guys enjoyed it I know we went
off a lot of tangents but you know you
guys seem to like that so remember if
you liked the show like share subscribe
on all your social media I know I said I
wasn't gonna do this anymore but I'm
just like used to doing it now but go to
our patreon page help us out support us
just like our cool people this week did
and we will see you on next week's
episode bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]